[Laughter]
hey everybody happy friday night oh yeah
they're okay i was wondering i was
wondering where the hell did i didn't
see any chat so i was kind of like are
we talking to nobody yeah
i didn't have it i didn't know what else
is new i didn't see a comment section i
had to reload it and then there's a
comment section yeah okay it came up but
i just i okay well you might be like a
couple of seconds ahead of me i think
i'm lagging a little bit behind i have
like a five second delay on there so hey
everybody how is your
friday going so far
yeah we're gonna sit here and party at
the house
party at the house i don't think we're
gonna be going out today
well
i mean the thing about it it's the end
of the month yeah we went actually last
weekend we partied hard because we did
the show friday night and then saturday
we went to
the temple of mercy slash obsidian show
and we not only went to that but then we
went to barbarella after that yeah and
stayed there until closing yeah so i
didn't drink that much though so we
actually i think i only had like two of
those little canned thingies over the
whole course of the evening so i didn't
actually spend that money but tom drank
a [ __ ] ton yeah
tammy's there what's up tammy camp guys
in
hey everybody yeah
cam guy said she his wife's gonna retire
soon
she just got home
everybody saying hi looks like like
retire like i don't know for good or
like would just retire for the evening
i was thinking about it the other day
i'm like i don't think i'm ever going to
be able to retire yeah
uh yeah i think probably
well
working from home and the businesses
that we're in would probably never never
be able to retire yeah i don't think i'm
ever going to be able to i mean unless i
win the lotto or something yeah then
i'll retire but otherwise i don't think
you're gonna you're gonna be writing
books to do a graphic design risk your
life bro oh probably i mean that's okay
yeah well there's a lot there's a lot
there's a lot worse things you can do in
the rest of your life yeah at least
you're not [ __ ] out running a lawn
mower which that's what the name of this
[ __ ]
that was the first thing
episode
past couple past couple weeks has been a
lawnmower [ __ ] adventure
lawn mower adventure think of this [ __ ]
man the new 2b original movie sick of
this [ __ ] man
not really but maybe i don't know what
lawnmower adventure was is uh
the lawn service that the old
owners of this house
uh had for this place they fell into
debt
all right oh is that what it was okay i
know i knew they stopped coming but i
didn't know why so i called him you know
i was like hey i'll be more than happy
to have you over you know what i mean
and do it i'll pay well he doesn't want
to work here anymore because this house
owes him money
not us yeah we just got our owners yeah
so he didn't want to work here
so then um
turns out the guy who lives up the
street who i talk with
his name is q he's from puerto rico we
just call him q he's ex-military guy
and uh
he's got uh a pretty good lawnmower and
he's over in puerto rico and he says
well you can use my lawnmower when i'm
in puerto rico as long as
you mow my lawn
so i mowed most of his lawn and the
[ __ ] belt broke i had to spend 75
bucks for a belt and i can't put that
[ __ ] back together
i told him i said i don't really want to
work on your machine because if i break
it
you know i mean you're going to blame me
it's like oh no no i'm glad and i was
like
no i'm not waiting into that quagmire no
way i don't know how this is going to go
and he's going to go no you can use my
lawnmower and then
if you
mow my long because he just came out out
of surgery you know what i mean
and i'm going nah i know how this is
going to go
that lawn mower is going to break
when he's on it he's going to blame me
yeah running my lawnmower dab
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's what
that's what's gonna happen there so
i went down to lowe's
and uh being disabled military and
everything i was able to get a lowe's
card
and they gave me a 7 000 credit line
trying to get my ass into debt
well yeah because they want you to buy
it's like here come buy all the things
you need for this house yeah so i bought
a
three thousand dollar [ __ ]
husqvarna ride on mower big old [ __ ]
v-twin mower
you say our best one
but the price difference was only three
hundred dollars more than than than the
other one i was gonna get but it was
better i was gonna i was looking at a
job dear
uh
but you know that husqvarna kept calling
me i was like that's a better motor
right mower and it's only 300 more
and really it's not going to make much
difference after all this shit's
financed on any kind of monthly payment
anyway
so i got a thing on a six-month
six-month interest-free loan
i could get a thousand down on it okay
and that will only be about after it's
all done and finally sixteen hundred
dollars and come pay sixteen hundred
dollars over the next
six months and there's and there's no
interest
well between me jenny that's only about
35 40 a piece that's less than it would
cost to hire a long crew
yeah it's going to be way cheaper way
cheaper so and then
in six months it's paid for and i have
to worry about [ __ ] long cruise
during this just put fuel in it and oil
in it and it's got a three year warranty
and it's
parts are you know easy to get and it's
well made so you can drive it it's got
headlights
you know it's got a place where you can
put your beer
because when you're [ __ ]
when you're rolling down that ramp and
jump over the [ __ ] pool you're gonna
need a place to set the [ __ ] beer
okay because um
[ __ ] like [ __ ] ramping the lawnmower
over the pool
well got the [ __ ] on video if we had a
pool if we had which we don't
[ __ ] that shit's on video where [ __ ]
you
rednecks in florida trying to ramp the
[ __ ] mower over the pool that sounds
like some dumb [ __ ] flurry with a hole
in the beer
over the deep end i've seen it the
[ __ ] had to be loaded well and
all his friends were watching and
laughing sounded like a good idea yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's like ridiculous
that's their excuse for everything yeah
then the next day they're like super
expensive lawn mowers at the bottom of
the pool and it's all fun yeah
they have to get another right
just go ahead and bite the bullet and
buy this [ __ ] lawnmower
and then i'd have
seven thousand dollar credit line with
lowe's so i could buy some paint and do
some [ __ ] around the house
yeah because really this is this i want
to repaint and my bathroom are the only
rooms that are that are painted well no
they're painted the other shirts painted
it's just well no i mean
that's what i'm saying we didn't paint
them like they weren't colors it's just
like a weird like pale
blue looking [ __ ] kind of like not
it's not even blue blue it's just like a
really like [ __ ] like very very
beautiful
i mean it's better than beige yeah
that's for sure yeah but i mean as soon
as we like before we even like fully
moved in i said well this is the office
this is where we're gonna be doing the
show from so i said i definitely want to
paint this and decorate this and so i
said well i might as well do the
bathroom too while i'm at it so the
bathroom's not the same color the
bathroom is green but um yeah yeah but
like chartreuse looking well it's like i
wanted it to look like because like i
said i think i mentioned this before but
the bathroom in there is like a um it's
like an alphonse uh musha or mocha uh
like art nouveau theme and that just to
me like associates with like absinthe
and that kind of like bell epoch kind of
stuff so it's like so it's like absinthe
color it says bathroom it's not a normal
bathroom it's a bathroom a dressing room
and a [ __ ] dressing table
it's it's like almost like two bathrooms
joined one of them has a shower or
toilet
and then a huge closet and then that
it's got doors that seal that off and
then next to it is another thing that
kind of looks like a bathroom it's a
dressing room with tile floors and like
a walk-in closet it has a walk-in closet
and a mirror and a sink and a new and
it's another sink and another place
where you know uh a woman could do
makeup and stuff so it's
kind of like it's a night it's a nice
bathroom right there although this is
the room that connects to it so it's
like a studio yeah it's like a studio i
kind of i kind of use that actually like
as my coffee station
because there's i mean the bathroom is
big enough to put my makeup on in there
so i do have like all my goth clothes
and stuff in this closet but
um yeah but i usually just use i got a
little coffee pot over there and over
here is a small bedroom that i've
converted into a gym it's got all my gym
stuff
and then there's a living room out here
big living room that has a refrigerator
in there i want to put a sink on the
other side and a bar
and make that like a kind of like i
think being a microwave too in a
microwave and a toaster oven telestrat
so that way you have to go downstairs
and do certain things because you know
with this the target is lazy yeah well
the top floors run is our office and a
business now we got we can do shipping
and receiving and weighing stuff and so
it's almost it's a business up here well
this that'd be a perfect place to have
friends over if i could get loaded and
have some entertainment stuff got a
really bad ass light system i set up
with [ __ ] colored smart lights and
yeah improve there's not much furniture
in it yet but there's just like some
chairs and a couple of little tables i'd
eventually like to have some like old
retro stand up
video games and stuff you know because
you can get reproductions for not too
not too expensive you know a couple
hundred bucks you can get a missile
command or a [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] pacman something stupid like
that something that looks
i kind of like the nouveau retro look
you know like a lot of people are doing
you know where it's kind of just kind of
80s looking yeah but neon and
colors you know
we'll see let's see what we do fourth
throw down said build a bar on the
lawnmower billboard
just kind of got one
[Laughter]
i'd like to have some side view mirrors
put a roof on it with a fan blowing
why don't you just make a little house
and then install a house a little house
so the cat can [ __ ] come yeah because
you know she's gonna be like well no
because she's like scared of anything
that's outside of me it's noise she
doesn't even she doesn't even like the
garbage truck or anything like that
she hears the garbage truck go by and
she's like oh no and she runs and hides
under the
under the thing she's not so much here
but um at the old house she used to
because she could really hear it and she
was just like i commented at me but
that's you know pookie does not go
outside at the new house which you know
well it's nice it's not even new anymore
we've been here a long time but
or since last september
but i'm kind of happy that she doesn't
want to go outside anymore i think it's
because at the old house
when this was like a year ago right
because it was when i was in saint
augustine and that was like last
not this past june but the june before
like 2021.
and when i was in st augustine
um
little pokey she was outside with tom
like tom took her outside and she was
like running around in the yard
and the neighbor had a new dog
and the dog wanted to come over it's
like ooh kitty and wanted to come over
and see and he said like the dog's like
super friendly and they had cats too so
it's like he really he loves cats so he
wanted to come over and meet her and she
was like absolutely not and she panicked
and she panicked so hard that she ran to
the neighbor's house and started
knocking on the front door let me in let
me in
there's like a big doggy monster and
it's coming to get me and like the poor
little baby and said tommy to like go
down it was like it was like two houses
down and he had to go get hers like this
isn't your house pookie why are you
knocking on the door it's like legend
and then she was running and she kind of
like
she kind of got her little claw like
caught on something right her little
like at the end of her little claw broke
or something and so her little foot was
hurt for a day or two but since then she
has been absolutely shown like
absolutely no interest in going outside
she likes to look out the window
and she likes to like in tom's bathroom
she likes to jump up on the toilet and
then jump up on the
on the windowsill and look out and she
likes to lay in
little sunbeams like coming in but
she doesn't really she doesn't want to
go outside i think it's because the
neighbor here has two dogs and they're
always in the backyard yeah before drove
down says jenny don't let tom go
driving through no flaming hoops on that
thing i know i i just gotta like you
know he's going gotta make sure that i'm
not drinking and mowing at the same time
you know you're going to because yeah
you make dumb decisions all the time
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man i hate doing this
[ __ ] and if i can make one of these
and i put that in the thing i'm always
alive
everywhere hold on hold on
it that might happen well it's set to
see we have to see how good it how good
i get with it you're gonna go out to the
lawn and it's like there's just [ __ ]
yeah it's like a tractor it's got big
wheels in the back and you know kind of
smaller wheels in the front and they
were you know they're i'm looking at the
brochures it's bragging about how tight
it can turn it's got a real tight turn
radius on it it's got a [ __ ] big wide
deck
i think it was 53 inches or 58 inches or
something it's got a big uh hopefully i
got room in the garage i don't know
where i'm gonna put those motorcycles
yeah oh yeah
yeah you can't leave these things out
uh they'll steal them well yeah there's
one of them got stole up
up the road it got stolen got stole
they got [ __ ] coming into this
neighborhood stealing mowers
maybe
well i don't know yeah i was gonna say
maybe you could put your motorcycles on
the back
porch or you could put the they'll steal
those two that's what i'm saying so it's
like i don't now i'm like well bring a
motorcycle into the house
maybe [ __ ] maybe yeah maybe i already
got one in here
i mean if that's a little i got my
little i am absolutely not helping you
carry the big ones upstairs i have to
leave oh no they weighed 380 i was gonna
have to stay on we managed to get that
little bitty honda up the stairs like
the two of us but that one's only like
100 something motorcycles are beautiful
anyway they're all custom like artwork
they're they're builds but xb's i got
xb12
that's half lightning and half firebolt
it's called a lightning bolt
and the other one is a
xb9
sx
super which is kind of like the city
cross and it's
it's a 1000 cc harley-davidson style
v-twin
a little bitty [ __ ]
rocket you know it looks like a little
kind of like a little dirt bike kind of
got a little supermoto with a giant
engine in it
motocross looking bars on i want to put
now that i'm out here in the country i
want to put i want to put uh [ __ ]
dual sport tires on it kind of
semi-knobby
so you can write it on on on
dirt if you have to
be neat to have
you know if i have to do some [ __ ]
if i have to do some [ __ ]
daryl dixon action you know what i made
up this [ __ ] deer in the
apocalypse i got a motorcycle that to
ride on a dirt and that
and the uh
the road
be nice fourth year down also says no
crop circles neither yeah no craps no
making no crops yeah i might have to do
that too so yeah
that might be a good idea while i was
there
i got two new two more papaya plants and
i got two
high you won't give a [ __ ] about these i
got two of these uh high high yield
uh banana trees they were only 10 bucks
each
wow cheap too bad i don't really like
bananas i had a banana tree out there
but it's it never did yield any bananas
and then [ __ ] i took a picture of it
and posted it on the place and they says
well that's not that banana tree is a
decorative banana tree it doesn't it
doesn't make bananas
so i'm like
i've had it for like three years
[Laughter]
wondering where the bananas were oh wait
you wanted that to actually grow bananas
no no that's not what that's a
decorative banana tree and i'm not gonna
think i'm gonna throw your ass out
but it's pretty you know what i mean i'm
just just probably just going
it came out of a big old planner we had
it at the old place
[Music]
probably bury it somewhere out in the
back where it'll get bigger look pretty
somewhere there's a lot of tropical
trees in here you know palm trees and
[ __ ]
but the banana trees look good
these banana trees actually they make
but it's going to take about a year
well like i said i don't really give a
[ __ ]
i don't hate bananas it's just not
really and i know that they're full of
potassium and they're really good for
you and stuff like that but
it's just i i just never really want one
i love them i just never really want
them i like them in i like them in
smoothies
yeah a lot of people like i like them in
smoothies mostly um with peanut butter
yeah that's okay but i'd still i would
rather not um well what i can what you
can't do with them is you can uh put
them in a banana make banana bread you
you don't mind bananas yeah i don't mind
banana bread actually so if you have
like a [ __ ] ton of bananas well just
like we had with like the [ __ ]
eggplants where we just had eggplant i
got a [ __ ] done an eggplant i got
eggplant like falling out our ass like
yeah there's so much of it past two days
i brought in probably a dozen eggplants
and they're still yeah there's enough
they grow like that's like something
right they realize there i didn't either
i didn't realize
i got about nine eggplant plants out
there and i can't keep up with them
yeah and it's like we made oh my god you
made like so much baba ganoush out of it
and then like you made like some [ __ ]
i made um
lasagna lasagna
with it you mean all kind of stuff
eggplant is expensive
at the store
you know this thing these [ __ ]
constantly make eggplants they said that
they uh they make yeah they said that
that's a good
eggplant breed for florida they're not
that big they only get about
about that big
but they put up they they they grow
quickly
you cut one out and you go back there a
couple days later there's another one
like god
you're like [ __ ] a couple weeks later
i can start trading these things
yeah go see if somebody's got like some
other i know there's a woman growing up
there her whole yard's a [ __ ] like
stephen he's got some honey or eggs i
don't know lots of people have honey and
eggs and all kind of blueberries and all
kinds of treated for eggs
yeah there you go i love eggs yeah camp
guys had another person killed by a
gator in florida this week elderly lady
fell into a pond yeah she shouldn't have
done it two seven foot gators got well
she was elderly i'm sure it wasn't her
choice she had to watch it man
you snooze you lose up in here man that
sucks man that [ __ ] yeah there's only
two kind of people man the quick and the
dead that's it
she fell in she shouldn't have done it
she shouldn't have fell in she shouldn't
fell in tom's victim blaming hey i'm
just telling you nature works man
[ __ ] it's not me it's nature nature
blamed her you fell in
i mean alligators are kind of like above
us on the food chain yeah they're like
sharks and you can't reason with an
alligator or a shark
they you know so don't fall in
granthars has asked us some questions
okay he's he's always good for for
giving us some discussion topics
uh well here's this one the shortest uh
one that'll take the shortest time to
answer are there many blue haired women
in eustis uh yeah well unless they're
old ladies no yeah
[Laughter]
you know you can go to the biker bar
over here you know and and see you know
redneck girls with colored hair it's not
really yeah it's not really all that
weird anymore not that weird anymore and
like i said she's she's a wig girl she
you know what i mean and a lot of goth
girls are wig girls now they just it's
much easier it's much easier
and a lot of the
biker type women are not
they're actually dying it
that's why it looks bad because it it it
takes a lot of work to keep that color
bright shiny oh yeah colors like this i
mean i had my hair bright red like i
actually bleached it and died good and
it looked fantastic but
it only looked fantastic because i dyed
it every single week if you didn't dye
it every single week and i only watched
it like once or twice a week otherwise
one red fades like super super quick and
it'll start like turning pink and you'll
start getting like all this kind of so i
really really had to keep on top of it
and every pillow was red
yeah she left like a red dye wherever
she went
and every time i would do it like it
kind of like started turning the shower
pink and stuff as well yeah
so you know and after a while i was just
getting her ass ready for a new photo
shoot because uh dimitri
he just hit me up a few minutes ago
and he was saying that uh
yeah uh the other jed his jen
uh uh jen and um
uh laura want to come down and do it do
a photo shoot
and uh i'll show you the girls i'm
talking about we were talking about that
at the last moment too yeah yeah
actually we took that
brian took that at our old house yeah
like a few years ago so we're gonna do
we're gonna jenny's gonna do a photo
shoot with them she's already done photo
shoots with him before jen uh the girl
in the red top she's actually the
vocalist for a band called 13th angel
and um
um
laura's just a long time friend of ours
laura's those are the girls that when
somebody will talk about you know where
they're saying all those good little
girls they're all [ __ ] and mean those
two girls are some of the nicest girls
you'd ever [ __ ] meet
oh yeah big time yeah
neither one of them has like a mean bone
in there no those aren't like the mean
girls and and they're like i'm probably
the meanest one
out of the three of us yeah actually i
know i'm the fetus one out of three yeah
and i'm not that big
and they you know they look like models
you know you guys saw them
uh but no they're not not a mean bone in
their bodies
but uh dimitri's like
he's like we're gonna make this [ __ ]
happen now with the bubble bath because
me dimitri has this thing where he wants
a photo shoot of majin and his gym
together and basically like a [ __ ]
lesbianic nude photo shoot
with bubble bath and they're in the ball
with with their with their boots
and
jenny's boob over his shoulder and
[ __ ] the other thing
sucking on it and [ __ ] that was crazy
[ __ ] and now now he's like oh we're
going to get lauren on this too man it's
going to be a [ __ ] lesbianic
threesome we're gonna have them all
decked up it's gonna look great we're
gonna you know
it's just this motherfucker's mind
running away with it but
[Laughter]
they they have a kind of a fetish
background those two they go to fetish
clubs and stuff and
he's a uh he's
he's a pretty well-known dj in this area
yeah he's a dj he's a good guy we've
worked for him forever and we used to go
these events and
stay at least
stay at hotels with them and [ __ ] and
we'd get [ __ ] blasted yeah like
vampire ball and kept the castle and
stuff
i was gonna leave it there
me and him high five and then [ __ ] and
[ __ ] um unleash the abdominal
abominable snowman
[Laughter]
they're [ __ ] laughing at my [ __ ]
stupid ass
rolling around
we should have recorded that
you know
it was it was very fun it was [ __ ]
hilarious
and i'm surprised that i actually
remember a lot of it even though we were
all like really really handy yeah we
were pretty loaded we were all really
hammering yeah
yeah but [ __ ] with that only fan is
gonna have to happen
we gotta have all those beautiful girls
in one spot with all that [ __ ] goth
outfits and all those damn cameras
yeah
yeah i'm already mad thomas got
yeah well like i said we haven't even
had anybody over to our new house yet so
yeah well no that's not true um yeah
we've got angel and mike have come here
angel and michael come over a couple
just
the house isn't really furnished that's
what i mean it's like this place is
furnished like i said the living room
rooms are furnished but not bad yeah but
yeah it's just kind of like sparse yeah
because this house is like quite a bit
bigger than our old ones so we didn't
really have enough furniture to like
fill up the [ __ ] and we don't really
have enough money and we don't have
enough a lot of money i mean that's what
i'm saying okay so i didn't really i
can't afford to buy a sofa i can't
afford to buy you know and uh another
thing is is that i didn't want to start
hanging up art and start buying [ __ ]
with the walls being the colors that
they are i want to put on one of my own
colors because i really don't like the
color yeah the colors aren't the colors
are boring
i could spice this [ __ ] up man it would
look really good when i get done with
but it takes time and you kind of got it
i don't really have the inspiration i
don't really know exactly the way it
should be we still haven't even we
haven't even decided like what color we
want to paint the bedroom yeah i mean
the bedroom at the old house it was red
it was red and i really really liked
that and we had a little bit i don't
even know if i'd call it a theme but we
had like a little bit the walls were red
and then we had kind of like a little
bit of an egyptian like an ancient
egyptian thing going on like we had
literally like red and black and gold
um and we had like a lot of egyptian
type art because we both had egyptian
art like i had a bunch of little statues
and little pictures the whole bedroom
had a pretty ceiling it did vaulted in
this is a very boring looking ceiling on
it it is i mean it's high but it does
have angles to it it doesn't have a fan
or anything it doesn't have a fan in it
it doesn't have places where track
lighting and [ __ ] accent lighting
would be but yeah the old one had it
what do they call it like it was like
almost like a tray ceiling where it was
kind of like it was like that and then
it was like up in the middle it was like
yeah it was cool again where it meant
the wall it was one level and then it
would vault up
into a flat area but it was it was a
more complicated ceiling it looked great
um it looked like it was it was built
for accent lighting that no one ever
installed yeah and we didn't own it so i
wasn't going to install it
but uh that could have been a fantastic
florida house this house is bigger
uh but it's
i gotta admit i like it better it's a
lot more efficient with the air
conditioning
the architecture is not as and the
accents is not as pretty
uh there was something about that house
because that house was mostly glass
which [ __ ] looked great
boy as you couldn't air condition that
[ __ ] i mean it was like every
door and it was glass and every
every [ __ ]
pretty much every room had all kinds of
[ __ ] glass windows in it yeah like
big glass windows sliding glass windows
which like i said it looked nice but
yeah it was always i don't think it was
always hot in there it was just it was
harder to keep it cool and like every
year or two the air conditioning would
break because it would override it it
would overheat because it was like so
trying so hard to keep it cool this one
well like i said this one's two stories
and it has two air conditioning units so
as far as i i mean so far
so far this is the first summer we've
been here but it really hasn't been
having any trouble it ices up like it
iced up the other day and like the guy
had to come
uh sort that out but
the electric bill is
really not bad at all yeah i was like
dreading it but it's really not i mean
the house is a lot more efficient than
the old one yeah um you know tammy says
i have a [ __ ] ton of zuzia zucchini
cucumbers and tomatoes i'll trade you
for some eggplant yeah i got
i got three different kinds of
tomatoes going one of them is kind of
like a like a beef steak type tomato big
but it was a special breed that grows
well in florida another one are the
little cherry tomatoes and i'm just
putting in aromas
all right
those tomatoes were [ __ ] yielding
faster than i could eat them i mean
every time i go out there there's more
little more little cherry tomatoes i'm
picking them and [ __ ] they're backing
up on me
um
so i don't need any tomatoes i'm
to get rid of the tomatoes that uh uh i
cook them and then blend them and then
cook the blend cook it down turn it into
tomato sauce
it's the only way i can stay on top of
them
um i don't have zucchinis but oh no what
else came in today
about
about um eight
big jalapenos came in ate them nice and
then about um
about 10 serrano chilis
we have little potatoes too out there
don't we too because yeah yeah i got
sweet potatoes that are about ready you
got sweet potatoes and you have those
little they're not fingerling potatoes
but they're just like those are regular
white potatoes but they're because of
the the weather and the and they're mini
they're kind of small uh it has to do
with it it's got it's too hot right now
next yeah tell me about it next year
they'll be bigger um
yeah that's what they all say
[Laughter]
it'll be big well when you're growing
them in cooler environments it'll uh
they they get bigger yeah i feel like
potatoes are more a cool weather uh well
they've made a big problem
i got six bags i'm using grow bags i got
six big grow bags of [ __ ] sweet
potatoes and they say those turn out big
i haven't checked them
but i just take a sheet out i lay a
sheet out and [ __ ] drag the grow bag
onto it turn it upside down and then
just
boom and then pull the potatoes out
and then put all the
put all the soil right back into the
grow bag and then drag it back over
there what were the peppers what were
the peppers that you put in your thai
curry that you made oh yesterday uh no
those those were those were store-bought
oh i thought you said dried ones no i
didn't put those in there
what i made two bottles of hot sauce
out of um
uh three
no four um
um
what those [ __ ] things called did you
just say it serrano chill no not
serranos
not ghost pepper i thought you said they
were good maybe this ghost pepper that
was just you said they were like super
super hot [ __ ] hot that was the
hottest [ __ ]
something because you said it was
reapers oh that's right carolina reaper
yeah and about that big i put them in a
put them on the wire on the metal wire
um
and put them in my small
uh air fryer
which has a
bunch of different settings but i put it
on broil
and i broiled them
blackened them on either side
and then i
threw them in with
some
pickled jalapenos with the juice
and then just hit it with a immersion
blender
and i also had some um
red chili peppers that had soaked in hot
water put them in there
and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] hot
i had
enough to fill up my hot sauce bottle
filled it up with a
what do you call it a thing
funnel
but then i had that much of it left in
the bottom of it this is what i'm going
to do with that well i had some french's
mustard
so i mixed that together and made hot
mustard and that hot mustard is [ __ ]
good
so i'm watching it to make sure there's
no decay happening
the last one it started to bubble
sitting there bubbling
and it's because i had roasted garlic in
there and that garlic started to ferment
oh
so you can't do it that's not good
so i'm just making sure as long as it's
vinegar
and vinegar type stuff and
there is a little bit of tomato in there
i blended up some of those cherry
tomatoes
i won't have there's a slight tomato
base in it but it's so acid nothing can
grow in it but i'm watching it they're
they're in clear glass hot sauce bottles
making sure that there's no decay
they've been in room temperature now for
a week and a half
so should be okay
they'd be rotten by now
we're giving off signs of rot
whenever i loosen the damn caps or the
corks i don't hear any hissing
so that means no gas is being released
nothing's blowing up or anything blown
up there's a pop of cork out of one of
them
yeah yeah my main hot sauce bottle is an
old tequila bottle that had a cork a
rubber cork which is sanitary rubber
cork with a
wooden lid on it
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] hot
it's yeah and you know it's hot if you
say it time yeah
because i love hot [ __ ] this is way hot
very concentrated when i mixed it with
that
it's mostly it's mostly
french's mustard
it's still hot but it's way more edible
delicious
be great on a hamburger or a hot dog
don't you be putting that on my
hamburgers or hot dogs
i like heartburn for days once i get
that [ __ ] right
i might offer that for sale
in a bottle and everything that jen
prints up the label because we have the
technology to make a bottle we have the
technology in it
i'll give you some that [ __ ] carolina
reaper sauce i don't think i can get it
to europe
but a large bottle of it
even if you ate that every meal that's a
cup that's a year's worth it's a big
bottle it's a big bottle
but and i feel like most people that use
hot sauce especially one that hot
usually just use kind of like a drizzle
yeah just a couple drips
if i get once i get this [ __ ] down i
like the flavor i just want to make sure
everything sells shelf stable
once i get that [ __ ] down if you guys
are interested i'll have jenny to design
up a real nice bottle for it i can
bottle it right here
for a super chat
i'll send it to you
speaking of which we got to do those we
got to do those uh shirts this weekend
too yeah
because we had yeah people wanted to do
shirts i wrote down they both sent me
their addresses so i have the addresses
and i wrote down and um
i went actually i went and looked at the
blank shirts
and happily
i had way more shirts than i remembered
i was thinking oh we had used a bunch of
like yeah so i went through there and
like went through all the sizes and i
was like well [ __ ] i was only short
about
10 15 shirts like of
various sizes but i had like pretty much
every size i had to order like a few
more extra larges i had to order a few
more mediums because i think we're out
of those but other than that we have
pretty much
we have at least like three four or five
shirts in pretty much every size which i
didn't realize
zach i think it's 98 degrees
right now 100 humidity
yeah i don't i mean my my computer here
is not right because that says 83 and
then yeah no raining and i was like yeah
that's not right i think it's maybe 83
in this room yeah i don't think it's 83
outside it's 73. no i'm just saying i
was just like there's no way that it's
83 outside it has been raining but that
doesn't usually make it cool off in
florida
um guys talking about several good
youtube channels on ferment and pepper
sauce you have to follow a very careful
procedure yeah you do you do
um
you go
as long as everything's cooked
and then once it's sealed properly and
you don't unseal it
as long as everything was done correctly
it could stay like that indefinitely
when you open it and start
start uh
exposing it to oxygen that's going to
knock it down a little bit uh well maybe
quite a bit maybe from decades down to a
years there's hot sauce i've had open
factory hot sauce that i've had open
longer than a year
although they probably put like some
kind of preservatives and [ __ ] like that
in there so that should last forever but
those those [ __ ]
those those [ __ ] uh carolina reapers
are so hot i don't think anything could
live in it
or maybe some extremophile i was going
to say one of those eggs at the bottom
of there
living by the thermal vents
it was lifting in your hot sauce it's
not
it's a modern pepper it's not that old
but uh evidently they say the guinness
book of world records they [ __ ] did a
whole analysis they said it is the
hottest pepper in the world
just one of them will make a huge bottle
of hot sauce that you can barely eat
i don't know i'm not i'm not casting
aspersions on people that like hot sauce
but to me
to me when you put hot sauce on
something that's like all you can taste
is a hot sauce and it's like to me it
just tastes like heartburn and pain
after a while though after a while
though your body sorts it out and you
can taste two things at once i mean i
don't you talk about i don't mind
jalapenos but anything that's hotter
than that even jalapenos will give me
harper not gonna lie but i do like
jalapenos but anything hotter than that
it's gonna be a bad time and honestly
it's that it's so heat forward that i
can't taste anything else i'm generally
a kind of person that and i've always
been like this i like to kind of taste
my food so i don't really like like i
don't like stuff with like tons and tons
of gravy or like tons and tons of
condiments or something even when i have
like spaghetti and meatballs i like like
sauce and stuff but not a lot i don't
like because i know some people like
pasta and it's like drowning in sauce i
don't like that i just like a enough to
just coat the noodles and that's it i
don't like everything to be like swamped
with gravy and stuff yeah now as far as
the the bottle
i got mine in a bottle that you can pour
or kind of shake it and stick you know
um but i don't think i'd sell it in that
i think it's probably because it's a
little messy because
when you dirt
you know you have to put the cork back
in and wipe it i didn't really like that
it would be probably better to sell it
in something like a jar like a pretty
jar
so you can reach in there with a uh a
spoon it's easier to control how much
you're using
with the spoon than throwing it you know
the consistency isn't isn't something
that's good for pouring
it's it's a little too thick
it's more something you could spoon it
onto something you could control it
better that's probably how i would sell
it if i did but it would have to have a
real cool label on it and the jar would
have to be right
a jar that not real wide but wide enough
where you can get a spoon in it
you know
it had to look right because i i like
pretty packaging it has to be i do as
well has to fit the product that well
that's one of my big things i guess it's
because i'm a graphic designer but i
really like
um
i mean i just just there's something
that makes me really really happy about
anybody it doesn't it doesn't have to be
food it could be any product it could be
a book it could be anything
but
if the form uh you know of the or the
content of the thing is like
reflected in the design of it it's just
like very very satisfying to me you know
what i'm saying so i really do like
i try to keep to like sometimes i'll go
through and look and like what's the
coolest like package design and so i'm
like oh look at that oh what a good idea
oh like that yeah i love that kind of
stuff this street right here
there's nothing but farms
and half of them
says on the outside little
little uh
sides
farm to table
and you can go in there and buy stuff
from them so this is like a farm to
table area
to where um
you just go in there and buy rabbits you
know there are chickens or anything you
know they can they're growing fruit and
their vegetables
they put upside what they have ready
and they're nice real nice farms you
know
look like something out of a [ __ ]
out of a movie
you know but uh that's what i would sell
anything if i would make this hot sauce
it's gonna be stuff out of this garden
here
unless it's gonna be something where i'm
gonna mix french's mustard with it or
something that's [ __ ] fantastic
so you know i'll be honest about what's
in it
when i give it
but um
that one carolina sauce that i have
there has my own
tomatoes in it too
made a difference that's like farm to
bottom yeah that's like farm farm table
[ __ ]
yeah and it's not mass produced it's
hand crafted
there you go it's a small batch yeah
handcrafted [ __ ] if i were to do it
you'd have a badass [ __ ] a bottle
and you'd be proud of that [ __ ]
you would keep the bottle when you're
done
well yeah that's the goal isn't it it's
like the bottle is like too pretty to
throw away right yeah that's what i
would want caleb higgins said why can't
fast food look like how it's presented
the commercials well because there's
something called a food stylist that's
not food half the time well no um
that well there's laws about that now it
used to be like back in the old days
that you could be like hey we have this
like burger percentage like it wasn't
even a burger it was like [ __ ]
plastic or something plastic yeah like
it wasn't plastic but they it was using
other things a lot of times when they
showed ice cream it wasn't ice cream it
was crisco
crisco
there's a law now as far as i know this
is a federal law that when you're
advertising food the actual food that
you're advertising that has to be the
food that you're showing you can't do a
thing like i said if you're if you're
briars and you're selling ice cream hey
look at this tv commercial and it's ice
cream and it's actually uh shortening
yeah you can't do that it ha they have
to actually show the now you can use
other [ __ ] for
you know uh other things like that
aren't the product that you're selling
like hey i'm gonna put chocolate sauce
on this we're not selling chocolate
sauce so we'll use motorola they don't
use that but i'm just saying they can do
that like if you're selling cereal you
can use like watered-down glue or
something like that like to make the
milk like just so it looks better looks
thicker because yeah because milk on
camera doesn't look that good yeah
neither does ice cream it melts
instantly well yeah because of the
lights but
i mean they they do have laws now but
the thing about it though it looks like
[ __ ] on on camera a lot of food does
well that's why food stylist is a thing
because even if you're using the actual
food you have to like sit there and
meticulously arrange it
you know so when they do like the
commercials even if they do a photo
shoot like from mcdonald's or burger
king or something you have somebody
that's like building that is actual food
but they're building
the thing and they're like pinning
the lettuce and the
tomato like in the place and like you
know putting a little steam thing behind
it so it looks like hot and everything
like that so you know
okay grampa is asking some more
questions uh i think we missed some of
the last ones but that was a long time
ago okay uh what world city has the most
goths
um you know what i don't even know would
it even be an american city i kind of
feel like it'd probably be a european
city i don't know
they have a bunch of uh
in germany and in sometimes in austria
and i think it was in hungary they were
having that traffic
treffing was when yeah
they do that every year yeah it's in
different locations isn't it
it's kind of like convergence
i didn't think they moved it i thought
it was in the same place where is it
germany
yeah it's germany okay because the
starry night played out at a couple like
last year it was germany that time but i
thought it was sometimes no it's always
just germany okay i think it's always in
the same okay well i thought that
trephin was the name of the place where
it was at but i could be wrong about
that right i'm probably just pulling
stuff out my ass i know convergence i
don't even think they do that anymore
but convergence yeah convergence was
that version of it they moved that
around like sometimes it was in new
orleans and sometimes it was it was
usually in the southeast though was it
not yeah i kind of felt like it was um
and then a long time ago back in the mid
2000s to the late 2000s they used to
have something that was more death rock
that was the drop dead festival and but
they always had that in new york city
and then um which is awesome i went to
it a couple years but um i think they
moved that to
not germany where the [ __ ] did they move
it maybe austria or the czech republic
maybe they moved to the czech republic
yeah that was like a several years ago
um used to be back in the 90s boston had
one of the biggest scenes that's i heard
that that's gone that it's small now
oh
louisiana used to have a pretty big
scene but it's it's pretty much dead i
think from from now it's a lot smaller
than it used to be um
la used to have a big one it probably
it's probably still pretty big
yeah i imagine it's probably still
pretty big um
new york it used to be huge they had the
vault
there uh that's another one i think it
was called it was called the vault
and then there was another
but i i don't think it's as big as it
used to be
well i think probably a lot of it isn't
well you know because a lot of people
aren't going out as much anymore because
it's expensive and
florida is surprisingly big
the castle was no joke that's one of the
biggest clubs and it's well it's still
there and that's been there for years
and decades that's one of the longest
running and
the thing about it is that the castle is
one of those places that cause you know
how a lot of goth knights are just like
a goth knight at another kind of club
yeah like where they play other stuff
the castle is not like that it's like
pretty much a goth club like all the
time and it's gotham fetish yeah and it
looks like that yeah like it's this big
and it's a massive massive building you
can see it on youtube just go to the
castle
it's a beautiful building
yeah
it's a beautiful building
so orlando and tampa has like a pretty
big yeah actually now it goes back to
the 90s you know [ __ ] on the saturday
night live when they used to [ __ ]
[ __ ] around with that
goth talk but it had cersei nightshade
and [ __ ] oh
these kids that were [ __ ] supposed to
be like having a talk show on a [ __ ]
public access
and though they were always fighting
they were from orlando and they were
always [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about tampa
and then they had one episode where it
was a funny show
fake show
and they had a girl from buffy the
vampire slayer what was her name [ __ ]
sarah geller right yeah sarah michelle
sarah michelle sarah shows up she's just
all decked out [ __ ] like goth
princess queen
and [ __ ]
okay and she and then they gave her a
fake name and everything and they were
like she's here from tampa
you know like
over there and just starts [ __ ]
just flaming on [ __ ] orlando but how
orlando's nothing but a bunch of
rednecks and [ __ ] they start fighting
that's [ __ ] great dudes but you don't
have the castle you know and you're
going on so whoever wrote those skits
was probably from here
[Laughter]
by the animosity between orlando and
[ __ ] uh uh tampa's gone
it very much was a thing though back
then it was but it very much was the
thing because and i'm not gonna lie i
mean tampa back then
was a better scene
they have the castle they have well and
the t and nowadays like tampa they don't
just have the castle they have several
other uh goth clubs and live
uh venues you know what i mean they have
like three or four different ones like
in a very very small area orlando has
more stuff than they used to have
orlando's had had eye bar
barbarella that's been there for like 30
something years they like i said
recently moved away from downtown but
that's not just goth they had like goth
nights there but that's usually that's
mostly like new wave in the oh just
alternative in general and and just
jen
and and and jen in our little company
does all the graphic designs for all
these clubs
all the castle mostly well i don't do
stuff for the castle i do stuff for the
dj's i do stuff for communion after dark
and i do stuff for um
what do you call it like for comedian
after dark their live
wing like where they do like the shows
that they present if you see a poster
that says comedian after dark and
undocks of booking present
voltaire or whoever the [ __ ] and you see
a poster i probably do and those those
are djs that are from the castle
i thought we did some nights of the cast
at least in the past i mean it's been a
while i've maybe i have done i have done
events there but usually usually my
stuff like for tampa is live shoes i do
all this stuff for absolution like the
big goth festival that they have there
every october and almost anything that's
anything in the orlando scene jenny does
it yeah yeah all the good [ __ ] that's
jenny i mean i do i do memento mori i do
uh most of mannequins stuff because
mannequins does other nights like they
have a drag night and stuff like that
but they do their own stuff um i do most
of the stuff for the friday and saturday
nights
see it's uh to do
i don't want to give way tricks of the
trade
but i'm gonna go ahead and give away
tricks in the trade yeah he's like i'm
not i don't want to do i don't want to
tell y'all i'm not gonna do this
yeah
uh pretty much any event if you want to
take over city it's basically a
three-pronged attack you must have a
[ __ ] badass venue
two you or a badass venue from
the point of view of what goths are
looking for you have to know what those
criteria are
it's not the best club in town no
no it's not the most popular club in
town that's not that's exactly the
opposite yeah we don't want that you
don't want that
so you have to know which one which one
to go for then you have to have a
[ __ ] badass dj
okay
and then you have to know what that is
what they're looking for there
and then
that dj has to have a badass ability to
produce
promotional material in other words
images that are trade back in the day it
was things like flyers all right and
posters
we still do posters
we still do flyers but a lot of times
that's a digital product now
and the same guy that does
spins and it spins at a club and the dj
is the [ __ ] star really okay the same
guy who does that tends to not have
graphic design skills those are very
different skills
it's like the league guitarist and the
drummer or the lead guitarist and the
bassist they're very different all right
but you have to have at least those
three elements together
and then the schedule that'll help too
what night are we talking about
what day there's scheduled domination
there's
gothic there's gothic [ __ ] blocking when
it comes to the calendar okay oh my god
[Laughter]
are you [ __ ] blocking the competition
are you working with the competition is
it is are are you at war or is this a
an alliance there's a bunch of different
ways because there's usually the problem
is that there's not enough market to be
shared effectively so they start to rob
from one another
okay that's that's the problem so
there's always
kind of this underworld
mob
war happening between golf clubs
i mean if you have more than like it's
not just like i said in orlando i don't
think we have like a goth club per se we
have goth knights
they're in venues but they're in venues
that you know do other stuff like other
nights yeah like i said they're usually
like all in the alternative area but you
know what i mean so you have that so
yeah there's kind of a problem where the
scene isn't really big enough
to support rich enough
frankly yeah there's not enough money
there to support
more like more than one
night so we yeah yeah it's like and you
know i know for real like we can't
afford to go to like two or three nights
a week no um
you know
so
most people can't yeah so it's kind of
like as much as you might want to yeah
that's a hundred dollars a night if
you're if it's a couple that's what i'm
saying and if you're a singer i mean if
you drink a lot and if you're a single
dude and you're trying to schmooze and
[ __ ]
and they're playing politics at their
own level they're probably spending
close to 100 bucks a night too
yeah yeah a player i can't believe when
i first moved to orlando and i was still
working um and i was still working like
a job that paid quite a bit
me and you used to go to eye bars every
night almost every night like even on
nights when it wasn't like we would go
to grits and gravy which was like the
old 50s 60s 70s night that was super fun
by the way we used to go to like the
indie night we used to go to like how
did we do that
that's what i was thinking i was
thinking about that i'm like how the
[ __ ] our bills weren't that bad that's
true because i was still living a little
bit i was still living in that teeny ass
apartment which the rent was like
nothing yeah and um
yeah so we weren't living together at
that time and like i said i had like a
regular nine-to-five job that actually
paid real decent that was basically rent
a room so right so it's like so we had a
lot more disposable income than we do
now because we weren't yeah i was still
working in the horse industry and [ __ ]
so yes working cash and uh i had friends
in the club industry so it was not as
expensive for me to get certain things
done at that time yeah and everybody was
younger and [ __ ] wilder even though i
was in my late 30s
i just can't believe yeah i was in my
late 30s too and i just got i was
thinking about that today i'm like one
how did we [ __ ] afford it two how did
i go to work every day and like work it
was like after being out like all night
because we went out
almost every i think we went out almost
every night
we went to eye bar
monday night drinks we would get bought
yeah well that's true
we would go monday nights tuesday nights
sometimes wednesday night sometimes
thursday nights then we go to venue 13
on friday nights and then we get an eye
bar again for new wave on
saturday nights now i don't think we
went out sunday nights unless it was a
holiday how much yeah there were times
where i couldn't buy a drink
yeah every time i turned around
somebody's buying me a shot a shot
remember that yeah shot attack
[ __ ] fireball shots yeah because
cookie shots oh yeah i remember those
[ __ ] snickerdoodle shots
jello shots yeah just i had one drink
and i could never [ __ ] finish it
hardly it was a strong [ __ ] drink
and then i get all these shots and then
[ __ ] it it was it was that was another
time i remember that yeah the scene was
richer back then
that was before all this pandemic
[ __ ] the economy was great
well i mean people had i think a lot of
people have since moved away
yeah yeah i think so so and i think some
people have made everything
they were old
like some people aged out because we
used to go out with a bunch of people
that yeah you know and sadly some of
them
passed away also because you know we
were in our late 30s and a lot of people
that were [ __ ] um uh just like
throwing drinks our way were 10 years
older than us sometimes so they've aged
out of the scene they're in their 60s
now yeah some of them were like yeah
we're getting at home
yeah yeah but you know
kayla higgins says did gothic culture
migrate from europe to the americas or
was it the other way around
i think it was simultaneous i it kind of
was i mean i think that's not how you
where you start counting i think most of
the yeah that's kind of like hard to say
because new york and and new york and
london happening simultaneously in the
punk scene between you know the ramones
and the sex pistols which is
they kind of had that that look that's
kind of where it started and then susie
so
susie was the first goth i think
i mean they had a lot of stuff most of
the stuff that we would recognize as
goth rock like is probably from the uk
yeah but a lot of the proto goth is
american like when you're talking about
like velvet underground and nico like if
you want to go back like this
in new york yeah [ __ ] like that so it
was kind of like going back and forth
like i said it's it's hard to say
because goth was kind of like an
offshoot of
punk and it was also kind of like an
option it was almost almost kind of like
a darker
uh
conglomeration of like punk and glam
yeah uh you know bowie and stuff like
that so yeah england made punk famous
with
the sex pistols
okay
and it started to become a fashion thing
but the sex pistols were also kind of
responded to what was happening in new
york back when new york was a poor city
like it was like detroit when everyone
was squatting
and everybody was playing at cbg yeah
and uh
it was
nancy you know sid's girlfriend was from
new york and she started dressing sid up
kind of like something out of new york
which was a leather jacket black jeans
spiky hair it was kind of a more
aggressive version of what like the
dudes from the ramones had been wearing
it's not that
different the difference was the
hairstyle shorter hair
versus america you know the british has
shorter hair with spiky dirty looking
you know and then they just started to
go in a more trashy root it kind of
became high fashion
the ramones were not real fashionable by
my standards to be they always look 70s
to me
yeah
i mean they didn't look like they just
had leather jackets and t-shirts and
jeans and just kind of long scraggly
hair and they didn't really like try to
dress up or anything nancy sid's
girlfriend was a new york hooker
basically all right and junkie
and she liked bdsm type stuff well
the sex pistols are being founded by a
[ __ ] malcolm mclaren
being funded by him and he owned a bdsm
shop
so she's sex yeah and so she started to
kind of like they could get real
discounts or get free clothes from there
as an advertisement and she's dressing
herself and sid up
in fetish attire from that shop
which helped with the goth punk kind of
look
so it was so i look man punk was an
american british american conjoined
effort i think that's the best way to
put it even though nancy helped make the
punk yeah nancy helped with the punk
image
and when sid saw when she went when
john lyden also known as johnny rotten
he was really the only sane member of
the damn band really okay i i like lyden
i like him to this day
he's a very self-important loudmouth
which i kind of love that in a certain
way well you're kind of like that to you
yeah he's kind of he's very he he's very
endearing he's he's a he's a smart guy
he's a um
came from nothing
uh
charismatic
and kind of repellent at the same way
but he knew that um that's a good way of
putting it charismatic and repellent at
the same time yeah yeah but he's the
kind of guy you really could get drunk
with and probably have fun with but
you'd probably fight with him yeah and
he probably loved that
he said when he saw the way
nancy was dressing sid he goes he looked
terribly
that weird vampiric goth look he called
it goth
and i think
he's right
sid was actually one of the first male
goths
that's why he that i would call that
goth yeah even though their music didn't
sound like that music wasn't god
but there's like i said it's just so
much um john smith is saying i would
argue dave bainian of the damned
envelope being gothic yeah david
and honestly i love the damned because
they started out as just a straight-up
punk band and i love all their old
punctuation well they almost became
people from like 1976 but yeah like as
it as it went on they got more and more
like goth rock and i was down with it
but i like their early punk [ __ ] too i
like that a lot fantasmagoria is almost
like a damn pink floyd album like a
gothic pink floyd album it is yeah
really good
um
but that was later we're talking about
the 70s well no the damned well the dams
came out in 1976. dave vanian had a
vampire style yeah uh but what that was
late 70s
yeah so i but it was still kind of a
joint thing
yeah it was anglo-american it was kind
of happening at the same time it's just
kind of like the whole punk thing it's
like in the whole goth thing i mean
honestly you had
um you know kind of like gothic rock
going on in like the late 70s early 80s
like bands that came out that were
influenced by bowie and then later on by
joy division and stuff like that but in
the us
particularly in la which is a weird
thing to think about but you had kind of
like a more glammy goth death rock kind
of thing where you had like 45 grave and
christian death and they had like kind
of their own sound yeah um you know what
i mean so it was kind of i don't know
it's kind of like a darker punk but also
like glam yeah now in that same british
scene
two other group two other well the mini
bands came here a lot of them okay fine
young cannibals
[ __ ] was a great band but it wasn't
goth or puck it was a new wave they were
great yeah a new waiver po i liked it i
like to say post punk because
that kind of is an umbrella term that
kind of like you can sound like anything
and just if you ever have you know to
find the young cannibals they were
[ __ ] great i forgot that dude's name
but he's rolling gift rolling gift
he's biracial he's i think
probably he's british and probably he's
an actor too do you know that he was
actor okay yeah yeah good looking guy he
was in some movies in the 80s i would
probably say he was half white british
and um half probably jamaican when you
say he's probably jamaican uh i don't
actually i do i feel like i do know but
jamaica don't really remember what it is
jamaica was a lot of crossover with
england because it was part of the
british empire and punk rockers listened
to to um
and new wave kids listened to to um
reggae they didn't like other music they
liked their own music and when they went
to a jukebox they wouldn't play prog
rock they [ __ ] put reggae in there
but he was like the british
black elvis i mean he did a [ __ ]
elvis cover of [ __ ]
suspicious minds it's [ __ ] great uh
elvis would have [ __ ] loved that
um
but getting back to uh
uh [ __ ] who's goth and who it was a
joint venture uh their
england was a small market and they
would pick up talent
use it for a while and get sick of it
and replace it with some other [ __ ]
pretty quick
and they would throw they would throw
axe away before really
they should have been done with them
you're like but england's a small place
so it would reach
market saturation quickly
well they also had national radio
stations like we didn't have that in the
us
so england was throwing away talent
duran duran and billy idol
okay
uh i don't i wouldn't say that they
threw duran duran away duran duran just
migrated out of there they threw billy
idol away
generation x was done
but that band did kind of suck
but guys really i like some other stuff
it just was that wasn't going to go
anywhere they were right probably not
that one that was that was done
but uh
a uh
chrysalis records i forgot which
executive it was saw
william broad or billy idol and says no
that guy's got a lot of talent we can
make something out of him and they
brought him to new york and hooked him
up with steve stevens and they're still
together
and really
america made billy idol that would have
never happened in england well yeah he
got hugely famous he got huge here and
what was great about him is that
he was a lot of like a lot of
anglo-american or our ancestors
who came before us they were coming here
and making a new life for themselves and
he
he used that as kind of like his ticket
in you know he was basically kissing
american ass it worked though
and he loved southern culture and was a
big fan of elvis and he felt a lot of
kidship with the south and
wanted everybody to know it and biker
culture and he mixed punk rock and biker
and redneck
it was a winning combo yeah and new york
and california i still like all his [ __ ]
from yeah and he
later on you know he's not a great
songwriter he's got to have a good team
with him and uh
really you know
the first billy idol album and then um
rebel yell and i think his best album
was actually whiplash smile
uh charmed life was great
uh and then his brand new one that just
came out it's got a couple singles
singles on it they're going to sound
like something from chris isaac they're
[ __ ] great real good he's good real
good especially for an old man he's a
old man now
grandfather
when he was young he was fun man
real fun and you could tell he was bad
you could tell he was doing drugs and
[ __ ] well they i kind of feel like most
of them were back then like 99 of people
in the scene like even whether they were
punks or gods or whether they were just
like doing regular ass pop music pretty
much everybody was on drugs but yeah
i mean pretty much everybody right but
his videos were great you know what i
mean it was goth
and punk and high fashion and bdsm and
[ __ ] motorcycles and porn and
everything just kind of and clubs and
drugs all just kind of mixed in together
into the same product it was just
good man real good good team
camp guy says uh would you say that the
who was kind of a precursor to the punk
music scene i'm a bigger who fan because
that's my timeline i must have come
along between the who and more ragged
punk music yeah i think there were a few
steps between the who and what would be
considered punk music i guess
like i said i kind of feel like i really
do like the who actually but i do kind
of feel like punk more grew out of stuff
like the mc5 or
the stooges like i said velvet
underground not so much punk but they
were kind of like more proto
goth proto experimental but i kind of
feel like
i don't know i guess listening to it now
there's not really that much difference
but i kind of feel like back in the late
60s there would have been
a rather large gulf between people who
listen to the who and people who listen
to the stooges yeah big difference even
though if you listen to them nowadays it
probably doesn't sound as different as
it would have to them back then yeah the
stooges iggy and the stooges
was before punk rock music but you
listen to it and boys sound a lot like
it is very punk rock oh man i was i was
at mannequins the other night and paul
vane the dj he saw i was there so he
played uh i want to be your dog and i
was like dude
[Laughter]
he doesn't usually play like [ __ ] that
old but i was just kind of like i
appreciated that if he sees i'm there
he'll usually play like nick cave or the
crap after i got out of the army and i
was hanging out in boston
i used to hang out at a place that's
gone now it's called the rathskeller the
rascal was all punk rock club
the pistols played there a bunch of
bands played there and i was hanging out
with old punk rock guy and he was old
den he was nearly 50 then and um his
name was ty tyrone only white guy ever
knew the name of tyrone and
he was um either friends with the dead
boys or in the dead boys for a while
he's always talking about that bad i
didn't even know he's talking about but
evidently that was like an old american
oh yeah yeah
baiters man yeah i didn't know anything
about it he was either in it or friends
with them i don't remember but he was in
some other bands tim bader's died didn't
he get hit by a car i don't know i kind
of feel like he got run up by a car but
let me say
he was talking about punk rock and where
it came from
and he told me it came from the rolling
stones but the rolling stones you never
heard
he said before the rolling stones ever
really got recorded this is way back i
guess late early 60s late 50s
so when they were a live band
and they didn't have anything recording
says they sounded like punk rock
and that he had actually heard
some recordings of early stuff that
never got released it was just
stuff that was passed around back in the
old underground it sounded like punk
rock but he said it came from this
the rolling stones well the thing about
puns
are the beatles
the thing about punk rocks
is that essentially what it is in its
purest form and this is like the ramones
seem to understand this which is why i
think that they're so universal
pumpkin punk rock in its purest form is
essentially speeded up rockabilly
is all it is which like i said which is
why i like rockabilly as well it's very
very similar like the structure of the
music is very similar it's just speeded
up some and kind of like rougher i think
it was the rolling stones it was a long
time ago that sounds great
he said very very early rolling stones
before there was mainstream recording so
it was punk rock he said something you
heard in a club
and and it was fast and really hard and
it was some of the songs that you would
know
and that later on they kind of chilled
out
to do those recordings and it's some of
the songs that you even know but they
played him differently live he said
i don't know if there's anything to it i
mean that's just what a drunk punk rock
guy told me
this might not be true but he was an old
guy yeah he was probably there when it
all yeah he knew the of the old scenes
yeah he said i mean we were there for a
lot of it but yeah i mean in the 70s i
was
fairly young i mean i was old enough to
know what was going on but
i was still like pretty young so he was
talking about early 60s that's what i'm
saying i wasn't around back then and my
parents were not into
my dad was real into music but he was
into
he's super into the beatles and he was
really into not so much um
like uh
british invasion type stuff other than
the beatles
but he really liked uh southern rock you
know like he really liked like the
eagles and
stuff like that so
but he got me into the beatles when i
was real little i think that was maybe
like
that was all the record so we always had
like music playing in the house my mom
like wasn't really into it my dad super
was
now uh john said that uh hold on
yeah don the bomb says stones just did
blues cover songs when they first
started yeah but what he's talking about
before they were ever even really signed
before they said that when they were
alive band
says it sounded like the sex pistols he
said it was really hard but then when
they started recording that they they
slowed everything down and made it more
palatable to the
but he said that when
when they were playing live before they
were famous he said they sounded like
the sex pistols did see it he said and
that they were dirty
and kind of ripped up looking
and that they were drunk
yeah
and that's well like i said you probably
got that more from live shows because i
kind of feel like back in those days if
you were doing a recording maybe that
was like a bigger deal so you try to
like clean your [ __ ] up because yeah but
when you saw like live shows it was
probably like a lot sloppier so ty told
me that's where punk rock came from
now there may be something to it i mean
it could be but like i said you know
it's just
because nothing comes from
you know it just comes out of nowhere
everything's influenced by [ __ ] that
came before so i think it's like really
hard i mean it's an interesting
discussion to have and i've had the you
know i've had the discussion many times
with people but if people have like
other
opinions about it like coming at it i'm
like willing to listen to that because
i'm like hey you know you might have
something there because there's i feel
like there's probably no real right
answer because everything's an influence
on everything else so you can't ever
really you can't usually ever really
pinpoint exactly like when something
happened there was so much influence
going on in like so many other
directions and like i said you know the
i don't know kind of like the history of
music in
just the united states
you know what we know about it there's a
whole bunch of other stuff like little
bitty scenes and stuff like that that
was going on that you know that maybe
people locally knew about that like
nationally they didn't know about that
didn't really get any traction but that
might have been
you know kind of influential on
particular because the thing about music
in particular is that it doesn't really
take a lot look at for example this is
probably like the you know an example
that everybody knows but like when the
sex pistols played at lesser free trade
hall in manchester um you know they make
the joke every single person there was
only like [ __ ] 20 people that get
maybe not even that many but there was
that only 20 people at that gig and
every single one of them started a band
that was like super influential and
there's probably something to that and i
think the same thing happened with say
the velvet underground who were only
known in like super arty like
underground experimental circles in the
late 1960s
but every single person that was into
that band
either started their own band or and
became really influential later on or
they were in some other like form of art
because it attracted
you know people on kind of like the
cutting edge of
of art whatever it was art music
whatever and the under the velvet
underground influenced american goth
bands big time big time big time
christian death and valor and christian
death
with jaton damone and everything you can
hear a lot she's basically doing like a
much better version of nico you know
male and female vocals happening on the
same album and stuff it's good very good
and i like [ __ ] [ __ ] onto mom i do as
well she's got a great voice yeah if you
guys know who that is she's just this
fetish
chick she's old now but man that girl
was so sexy when i was a kid
she was there in her 40s then this
blonde white
blonde fetish
i love she did kind of like um
she almost went i don't want to say it's
like lounge
but it was almost kind of like that kind
of style to it but it's still like a
gothic edge to it and she's like i said
she has a gorgeous voice yeah two i
recommend is on a christian death song
called 1983 a merman or mermaid i should
turn to be this is a jimi hendrix cover
she does a [ __ ] great version of that
you might be able to get that on youtube
and then she did one called incendiary
lover oh that's a great thing yeah she
that was so low it's real good yeah
that's a really good song i have that on
yeah
yeah she was actually very blues
influenced i feel like which is weird to
think but
it's not that weird because if you look
at somebody like nick cave
and his old band the birthday party from
the late 1970s were i mean they were
australian but they were really really
into american like delta delta blues
music an old country yeah like johnny
cash and stuff but mixed with punk
so it really came out and because they
were from australia and they didn't
really they weren't in the culture where
those things happened
they came up with like a really
interesting different take on it
variation and honestly still to this day
the birthday party are one of my
favorite bands ever they're not for
everybody
but um you know if you if you like nick
cave uh you know because he got a lot
mellower like as he got older but uh i
mean the birthday party [ __ ] is like
really really good it's like like i said
it's
strange it's kind of like out there but
yeah very it's very bluesy but also like
noise punk it's i don't know it's cool
really the cave is a trip fake southern
music
it's good though
yeah and it's good but you know
he's like really romanticizes
romanticized i mean if he his second
solo album which is called the firstborn
is dead he does a song on it well that
whole thing is basically like a [ __ ]
up weird goth blues country album and
it's fantastic i love it but the song
like the kind of uh you know the the
most famous like single from it is
called tupelo and it's all about elvis
and how elvis's uh
twin was born dead yeah like it's and
it's almost like this fairy tale
telling of it it's great like he's
really good at like doing like story
type songs the stones did that too
though yeah yeah similar it's similar
stones made a whole career about
being fake southerners you know what i
mean yeah fake southern accents and
everything but well it's romantic to
them because they didn't grow up they
didn't grow up here but i mean to me
it's just kind of like
because i'm from here but it's like if
you're not from here it seems exotic
yeah wild horses the fake southerners
yeah i love that strong fake southern
accents but you know it was accepted in
the south you can go to these [ __ ]
biker bars in these southern but yeah
they'll play that [ __ ] not even
realizing that that's a british band
yeah
you know what i mean
because it's they grew up with it white
horses
you know and then [ __ ] just
a lot of [ __ ] is mick jagger is [ __ ]
doing a fake southern accent but but hey
man
[ __ ]
starry night doing fake british accents
go either way
that's all right yeah it's all right
just you do you yeah do whatever you
want
don the bottom says the curious
pornography was probably a big influence
on the gothic scene oh definitely
definitely and actually that's still to
this day my favorite cure album although
although their hardest album although i
will say that that did come out that
didn't come out until 82
right so there had already been i mean
bauhaus had already been making records
for
well they had already almost broken up
by that time they broke up in 83
actually so they'd already done like a
few albums by them so many good cure
albums they didn't really have a bad
album
wish i was i thought it was terrible
when it came out but it aged so well a
couple of decades later i'm like man
that's a great album yeah i didn't like
it when it came out either but then yeah
if you listen to it now you're like wow
that's really good yeah it was one of
those ones that like needed some time to
like takes torment takes time
no pornography
great cure album that's the one you want
to start with especially if you're
pissed off that the very dark album
uh the top i've really loved the top
with caterpillar girl and [ __ ] one of
them that was that's one of their most
diverse i feel like because that had
like some weird like spanish kind of
astounded stuff and like that and stuff
yeah and then like we're like tom waits
kind of sound and stuff and like you
know
it was crazy
some people go on about
kiss me kiss me kiss me [ __ ] great
album fantastic also quite diverse i
like i like that they have like a bunch
i know that everybody
that doesn't know that much about the
cure they kind of feel though they're
all like moby gods and stuff a lot of
their stuff is but
they have like a lot like uh of diverse
yeah especially like on their earlier
albums like you said kiss me kiss me
kiss me that is all over the [ __ ]
yeah
was good all kind of style head on the
door was good faith was good
um
they didn't have any bad early albums
swings wasn't bad it was good was that
the one with all the remixes what are
the no that move swings was uh 2008 i
think oh okay i didn't buy that one it's
pretty good
i think the last one i actually bought
was disintegration so that was a long
time ago
yeah discriminated
disintegration's a great album
um
south in south park
south park considers to be their best
album no their best album is probably
pornography i mean pornography is my
favorite i tend to like their older [ __ ]
i like their [ __ ] when they were still
like when they were still skinny kids
with pimples yeah that were kind of like
a weird-ass punk band yeah boys don't
cry like boys don't cry yeah like that
era like 1979. that goes the same with
you too you two's first time like boy
and war those were [ __ ] great yeah
and then again and then later [ __ ]
high flute and [ __ ] well they
got a little self-important yeah by the
foot the [ __ ] was still good it was good
but but their last their last really
good album if yesterday was octone baby
i liked it it was good it was all right
it was mainstream as [ __ ] it was but
that was good mainstream music for the
time i would probably like it if i
listen to it now
it pissed me off at the time
it aged very well but in the context of
the time like you said i wasn't a huge
fan of youtube i loved their early like
their early 80s stuff
but after about
i think after joshua tree i liked joshua
tree that's 87 when joshua tree came and
i was kind of like oh okay i like that
but it's like i didn't really feel the
need to like carry on with it yeah
because i wasn't a huge fan of them to
start when joshua tree came out i
listened to that i listened to it on the
radio it's like i can't stand this [ __ ]
uh but
you know what
after the overplay was gone because
yeah on the record all the time albums
they killed you on the radio with that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] day i did not want to
hear anything off the [ __ ] joshua
tree but then uh years later
um i listened to that album and [ __ ]
that's a great album bullet in the blue
sky
yeah just so many i like that song so
much better that's a great all this
stuff now that i did back then all the
[ __ ] that they weren't playing on the
radio was [ __ ] great off that album
it's a great album uh and then you know
after it's aged well you can you know
listen to the radio play stuff and go
yeah it's good it's good
because yeah it is pounded into you i
think that might be a big factor i don't
even think that it's just that i'm
getting old or [ __ ] like that but
now i'm bombarded with yeah because like
back in the 80s like i liked a lot of
[ __ ] in the 80s but i tended to like
stuff in the 80s that didn't get played
all the time that's why i liked like a
lot of underground stuff which i still
listen to nowadays because you didn't
get sick of it you didn't like every
time you turned on the tv or every time
you turned on the radio
it wasn't on
um you know whereas stuff like like
mainstream [ __ ] like madonna and stuff
like that was on like all this like you
couldn't avoid it
so
you didn't like it as much now it's like
a lot of it i still don't like it but it
doesn't piss me off the same way that it
did back then because i'm just like oh
my god shut up it's like this looks like
this is always on and it was just like
they were just it seemed like they were
shoving it down your throat but now that
you have like some distance from it i
mean [ __ ] we were at barbarella last
saturday
and he played uh at the end of the night
like right before they closed because
usually this is what they'll do they'll
play like new wave goth ebm you know uh
synth pop kind of stuff like all night
and then like at the very end of the
night like the last couple songs he'll
play like you know george michael you
know i want your sex or faith or
something like that and then he played
madonna but i think he played burning up
right like so it was like an old because
uh our friend will was there he's like
man this is like studio 54 aaron madonna
i was like yeah that's you know and i'm
down with that i liked everything up to
about get into the groove and then after
that i was kind of like yeah no thanks
but um yeah because she was kind of like
a a scene kid prior to that before she
got real famous
but yeah so they'll play that and it's
like even nowadays i'm just kind of like
you can appreciate it you can appreciate
it because you have some distance from
it you're not hearing it every day like
he used to back in the 80s and so you
can appreciate it as a song you actually
can you you have it at arm's length i
mean like i said even songs that i
really did not like back in the 80s
because
like you said they were super mainstream
like michael jackson or holland or hall
and oates or something like that
um you know because i haven't heard them
for so long if i hear it now i'm like
you know what this is this is a pretty
good song and i don't think it's just
because i've gotten older no it's
because you're not being barbarouted
because i yeah because honestly as i've
gotten older i think i've gotten even
crankier than i was when i was younger
so i don't think that it's like a case
of me getting less cranky i think it's
what ruined you two's career if you ask
me their you their their career did get
ruined as a [ __ ] pop band
even though i imagined that they could
make a [ __ ] ton they could probably fill
a whole [ __ ] coliseum oh yeah they
probably still could get a thousand
dollars a ticket they probably still
could
but to me they just kind of
bono realized that he didn't have to be
a rock star
that he could make more money if he just
walked around and collected money for
charities he could be a messiah he could
just be a messiah
he made him a living smell in his own
farts and that [ __ ] thought he
was jesus all right and
always always dangerous yeah that was
dangerous i checked out like when
[ __ ] douche i mean he's a douche he's
a douche i know he's a douche and the
thing about it is like even people even
large segments of population who would
agree with him otherwise
still think he's a douche and that's a
bad that's a bad sign that's a bad sign
when even people that are on your side
still think you're insufferable
you maybe you need to like tone it down
a little bit a little bit uh camp guy
said i read that the rolling stones used
to have liquor bills a thousand bucks a
week when they were living together and
recording and that was back in
i'm not sure whether to be impressed or
horrified
you have to understand though i mean
that's not it's not just them well
between all their friends and all is it
their friends and crew and stuff like
that okay then it's not having a party
then it's not that great and they're
probably buying the good [ __ ] too i mean
i would too if you look into the details
during the time when
um
okay like during a time when when um
billy idol was recording albums like
charmed life and and and [ __ ]
whiplash smile down in la
they recorded for nearly six months
but most of the time was partying and
[ __ ] and and [ __ ] porn stars
because it was it was like a studio
slash it was like a
an apartment that they were in or a
house that they were recording in and it
was just packed with
porn stars and friends and it was an
orgy
and then they would
a big drunken they get drunk they'd wake
up and the girls were gone get the [ __ ]
out of here see you guys in a couple
days and then they'd try to record some
more and that [ __ ] would go on for six
months at a time i mean to think about
it like i said if you think about it it
was a party like the last time when we
were at the old house and we had a big
party yeah i'm trying to remember how
much we spent on booze
i don't think it was a thousand dollars
but it was a lot it was in the hundreds
yeah big time yeah it might have been
half that
uh some people brought their own i'm not
saying like some people didn't bring
somebody but man i had a good layout man
it's all the indian food and it was i
still think fondly of that party that
was a great party the vegetarian stuff
was vegan because we knew i knew i was
going to have some of them
so well because you had brian
the vegan black metal chef actually he
brought his own dishes as well because
he's a chef and he's also vegan
but we did make some vegan stuff yeah
you guys can look the vegan black metal
shaft he's buddy mom
and uh
that's it right yeah i fight with him
all the time over online over [ __ ] uh
the war going on in ukraine but he's
like yeah you're right man [ __ ] russia
is winning i said i told you they were
gonna win you know don't listen to what
they're saying this is a david and
goliath thing russia's army is [ __ ]
huge and they're only using one small
part of it
but anyway i knew that was going to go
down that way
but he's a good dude he's been on a
bunch of he's been on [ __ ] nbc and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] he's good dude
uh
yeah he has a channel he has a cookbook
which i designed by the way yeah
he dresses up like like gene simmons
from kiss and he'll [ __ ]
he's got his own youtube channel he'll
uh doesn't he
yeah
yeah
but that's not what he does he's in a
bunch of other bands yeah they hire him
i don't know and he's one of the he is
honestly like if you don't know like if
you've seen like his uh channel and
stuff like that but he is honestly like
one of the nicest dudes ever yeah
he's seriously one of the nicest dudes
you'll ever want to meet he lives too
he's trying he's working on cuz so
you're getting a little bigger oh thanks
man you're the biggest guy i know i'm
gonna start
knock that [ __ ] off because i said get
on that magics we just saw him we just
saw him on saturday
get on get on the magic sauces i don't
know man he says dad you're old enough
man get on the magic sauce man get on
some tape magic sauce yeah call it the
magic get on some tests and this and
then because i don't know if that's even
vegan and i says what the [ __ ] you
talking about
i don't know if that's vegan i gotta
check well no you do have to check
because you you know lord knows what
they put in [ __ ] stuff
you know what i'm saying
i'm just saying
if you've made the commitment not to eat
that stuff you don't want to eat that
stuff you're not eating you're injecting
it well it's still going in your body
okay that's okay like i respect
everybody's [ __ ] decisions man
you just you you do you and you do the
work day
well you don't get it because it's not
you
tom has yet to figure out that everyone
in the world is not him
that's the problem with the world
uh
i don't think that's a problem if
everyone was like you we would all be
really really hosed uh i'm just saying
that right now tammy said bono and sting
need to get together and save the world
yeah right [ __ ] sting i mean sting
steve sting isn't much bono is a bigger
deuce than stink but yeah i mean sting's
kind of like a micro douche dude he's
kind
is the spiritual [ __ ] that's
trying to [ __ ] your wife that's what i'm
saying he's more like let's do like
six hours of like tantric sex yeah we're
gonna do some sex i'm gonna sit like
that's okay he's not hurting anybody
yeah you sit on my [ __ ] and we'll listen
to my album and then you'll come i love
i love the police though yeah so i'm
just gonna say and i think he's a good
team that [ __ ] in a long time he's a
good actor too i guess he's totally
retired now huh
i don't know i haven't seen him in ages
i wonder what he looks like now i don't
know i haven't looked at him in ages
he's hiding i don't know
probably he's probably unrecognizable i
don't think he's hiding didn't know so
did we talk about did we have this very
same discussion probably like six months
ago oh maybe and somebody sent you a
what he looks like now like what he
looks like now and he looks totally fine
okay like he still is recognizable as
staying like he doesn't look like an old
fat bald man you're right yeah so i mean
i i still think he looks like i mean he
looks older
val kilmer is unrecognizable
well val kilmer has
he has issues yeah
didn't they make that documentary called
val which i actually kind of want to
watch which is like sort of all about
his
he's got issues
i mean we've all got issues but val's
got issues i think he has mental and
mental issues and and physical issues
that's what i'm saying yeah but uh val
cameron's [ __ ] totally like i said
i'm not hating everybody's got issues it
just like depends on what they are but
the honestly sting
um
i'm gonna say synchronicity their 1983
album
that was the first
album and it was an album it was on
vinyl that was the first album that i
ever bought with my own money
you know what i mean i bought other ones
before that but yeah that was a good
album that's a really good idea and i've
loved it i mean i had other albums
before that but other people had given
them to me like for birthdays that was
the first one that i got to the store
and
buy the older albums but i never got
around to buying the older albums i had
some of them on tape well i have had
greatest hits type stuff i wanted uh i
wanted uh ghost in the machine
i never had it i don't think i even
heard everything off that album
i got it later but i don't know what
happened to it i think i had on tape and
i threw out a bunch of my cassettes
because they were all [ __ ] [ __ ] up
ghost in the machine the other one was
what was it zimbabwe
what's it called this imported
what was the name of that album zendata
madata yes
it was the orange album with the
triangle and there yeah coming out of it
that had a bunch of good stuff on it i
never got around to buying that other
early [ __ ] was good yeah
all the early shows yeah i mean
synchronicity is my favorite but
yeah and police came out when we were
kids
yeah i think i was only 11 or 12 when i
bought that album
and i loved it i listened to it i was in
high school when i got synchronicity i
was like a high school student i was in
junior high school i was in high school
that was 83.
you were in high school in 83 no you
weren't that's just when i bought it oh
okay oh you bought it later i bought it
i bought it like right when it first
came out so i was in junior high school
actually no
i think i was still in elementary school
i was in elementary school i bought it
when i bought for a while when i bought
it oh okay i bought it when it first
came out so i was still in elementary
school no because they had synchronicity
one and two on it yeah
and i about the loch ness monster about
the loch ness monster
i kept getting what was about a bunch of
other stuff i mean it's about a bunch of
other stuff but that was what i splashed
on stuck in my head
so i bought it
and i loved that album had miss gredenko
in it
remember that mr podenko had uh walking
and walking in their footsteps walking
in your face in your footsteps yeah
there's a lot of stuff about dinosaurs
on there yeah it was about dinosaurs
yeah that's
dinosaurs dinosaurs
it was more than that too you just gotta
listen i mean you know we're we're
making fun of it
but uh i make fun because i love you
yeah thank you dominic people for
sending us money you guys will remember
to send us money glad to see your new
channel is picking up i'm really
enjoying it so far hope everyone here is
subscribed yeah go subscribe to my new
new channel let's scare salon um i'm
gonna be putting up two videos a week
about horror [ __ ]
uh and i'm gonna do a true crime channel
too i'm hoping to get that up august
first but we'll see i'm editing the
first video today and i already have
like a whole month's worth of videos
like planned out but we'll see how it
goes but i'm editing the first one today
and it's almost done so you know
um yeah
but uh yeah synchronicity that had it
also had um
uh it yeah it had walking in your
footsteps it also had uh
what was that other one the the video
with all the candles
oh um um
god damn it what the [ __ ] it just went
right down
yeah what the [ __ ] was in here
it'll come to me like five seconds five
minutes from now it's right on the tip
of my tongue
[Music]
i mean that also had like every breath
you take on it right
yeah i'll be wrapped around you wrapped
around your finger yeah that's what it
is
yeah wrap it around your fingers that's
a great song
that whole album was good yeah except
for except for the song mother i wasn't
a big fan of that one
i love that one although it's all insane
i probably like it now well i didn't
like it at the time because i was like
this sounds like it doesn't really go
it sounded like it was like kind of like
out of left field like it was yeah it
didn't really go with the theme yeah
about this girl that's taken over your
life and she's now just become your
mother
that's what it's about
well yeah i know that but
cigarettes and making you smoke or
making you not trying to smoke and your
laundry and just i had all kinds of [ __ ]
it was a good song and um
yeah but i was always curious about i'd
heard
everything off i'd heard at least one or
two songs off of all the other albums
but i never had the albums we had
limited income back then we were kids
you know and i didn't really hang out
with the but with the group of friends
that had police albums where i could
[ __ ] get it get a tape
so i had to just like uh put up with
um
uh getting greatest hits albums and and
and i got synchronicity
and uh that was it
uh you know i knew that there were i
would hear [ __ ] on the radio
just the way it was back then you know
it's another era if you guys did like
tape stuff accident like today these
kids are spoiled you can go on youtube
you have access to that awesome god i
wish that we would have had all the
[ __ ] songs i wish you would have had
that back in our days you had to buy
that or get somebody to [ __ ] or if
you had a friend
because i don't have any money you don't
have any money right so and i can't
afford to buy it because you couldn't
afford to just like buy all the albums
you wanted jesus yeah i was buying other
albums i have [ __ ] album collection
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dick you know what
i mean
and then sometimes uh
with your friends you trade album yeah
look look man give me that one i'll give
you this one if you don't like it we'll
try it back okay yeah yeah then you
never worry about it he'd never give it
back
so uh i was more worried at that time
about metal and goth and albums that
were coming out and um
trying to get the roger water albums i
was trying to get roger water albums at
that time which is that was like the
pink floyd
spinoff get uh trying to think all the
other [ __ ] that i was trying to i was
trying to get all the slayer albums
which were hard to find you couldn't get
show no mercy
it was too old it was out of print
um
and everything was on an old metal blade
album the metal blade um
was the uh the record company that made
me man i remember gwar being on metal
blade for a while
metal blade was like a little small
album yeah i remember that i remember
that label back these obscure [ __ ]
like i said well dan was on that [ __ ]
like that
that's really funny yeah but yeah that's
the thing it's like at least i had like
a few friends in school
that were into some cool [ __ ] so like if
they bought something
you know hey i got this jean love
jezebel album or hey i got this uh you
know cocktail twins or something like
that i'd be like hey tape it for me swap
to buy it because i wanted to buy it
because obviously i couldn't afford you
know i was still in school so i didn't
have a job or nothing and you all kids
are [ __ ] spoiled man we had to walk
10 miles ago
it's all spoiled because um you have
instant availability but like i said
that's awesome man we didn't have that i
wish we had had that back we didn't have
it yeah i wish we'd have the you guys
are really lucky we'd have to go to like
harmony house records
and go i'm looking for this record this
and that and then they'd go through the
catalog to see if they could order it
and they go oh yeah now we used to have
it but we can't get it for you
and no so that was it that's a wrap
okay man isn't it crazy
now but not you couldn't get it back i
worked at a record store in the early
1990s
like when i was in my late teens early
20s
and they didn't have the internet really
back then so somebody came in asking for
some obscure [ __ ] you had this massive
book it was like this big yeah it was
like a phone book but the pages were
blue and you had to like kind of go
through there and see if you could like
[ __ ] order it and then like 50 of the
time somebody would come in yeah and
they would order it and then like you'd
order it and then they would never show
up to pick it up yeah half the time but
i saw this uh
this little [ __ ] little dweeby
[ __ ] who is
doing some kind of show on youtube
these [ __ ] silly glasses and he would
hang out with these celebrities and uh
talk about music with them
and uh this is some time back maybe 10
15 years or 10 years ago
and his guest is [ __ ] snoop dogg
and snoop dogg's going through his
record collection it is how this guy
other guy's record collection all right
and he's going he's looking through oh
you got that you got this because you
know snoop dogg is about my age he might
be a little bit younger
and you could tell he was from the
record era
because he goes through and he goes oh
you got blowfly it blow flies oh my god
yeah and he just goes this is mine
because you're gonna take my blow fly
out and he goes yep and he handed that
off to a [ __ ]
handed that was like well at least give
me a couple of fat for that no i just
took his butt
i got that i got that that's mine that's
[ __ ]
stole [ __ ] stole his [ __ ] blowfly
album how cool snoop dogg you can afford
to buy your own blue play
but the thing is is that you can't find
them
yeah you can't find them but i mean
snoop dogg has a lot of money i'm just
saying if you really wanted blue flight
i could buy some blue flames dog lives
down in [ __ ] miami and that was that
that took place down in miami do you
remember that at will's pub a couple of
years back blue fly played there yeah
they still have the flyer like framed up
on the wall i think we missed it but
yeah he's dead now yeah he's dead now
but yeah we for because we were gonna go
and then i forgot about it yeah blowfly
[ __ ] is out of print yeah uh you
might be some company that has rights to
do it but
snoop dogg knew exactly what that
blowfly album was
and go oh oh i'm taking this yep thank
you because what you're gonna take my
blue fly up yeah yeah he handed that off
to a [ __ ] some dude that was with him
man i wasn't a random celebrity coming
to my house and stealing my blue flag
in the face
[ __ ] nerdy
nerdy little white dude because no no
i'm taking that i don't care how nerdy
or how white the person is i'm not
stealing from [ __ ]
right especially especially if i got
enough money to buy the [ __ ] myself
snoop dogg
go buy your own [ __ ]
don't be that way
it was hilarious that is like not that
is not classy it was hilarious not
classy
like i said that's not funny
you wouldn't think that was funny if
somebody came in and like took your [ __ ]
like that it's like bye take it and bye
oh you're too weak ass to like do
anything about it bye
it was just part of the show i was
laughing just laughing hopefully after
that yeah he's like just kidding i'll
get it they kept they kept hanging out
because i'd be like oh you were not
leaving your house but you were not
leaving my house yeah
hanging out talking about i'll take your
head off going through going through his
record collection talking about this and
that and the music but he took the
blowfly album
oh no no i'm taking this
that's it that's it
am i taking my blood flavor because yeah
yeah that's mine that's mine now
who knows maybe he paid for it
i'm kind of thinking like hopefully they
edited that part out where he was just
like here let's see here's here's 50
grand or so i don't know or here's some
really super good weed whatever the [ __ ]
adriana c says
excuse me tom did you have a metal look
or a goth look back then
well how long do you wave how long ago
are you talking about it because yeah i
went through a couple different um
by the time 87 had rolled around it
looked like something somebody drained
around
yeah cause we're all in it somebody
mentioned earlier about how uh the new
romantic look was really influential on
the goth as well yeah yeah i kind of
feel like there was a whole see if i got
any old pictures i mean the new romantic
thing that was very that was late 70s
early 80s because i mean duran duran
formed in what 1979 right yeah and then
their first uh album for single planet
earth like came out 81 and they looked
very very uh near romantic you always
had like you also had like steve strange
from visage and they had uh blitz and
all that kind of stuff
so
i kind of feel like that was kind of
like a
they kind of like sounded like punk or
like post punk
but it was also kind of like a backlash
against punk because they're like well
punk they're all like dirty and poor and
everything like that we want to look
glamorous
so they're hearkening more back to glam
this is me at about 16.
um that must have been 85
probably
and i was just starting eyebrows yeah
yeah [ __ ] that high testosterone i
was starting to get into kind of like i
was just starting to get into like
sisters of mercy and bauhaus around that
time
um and then later on it was more kind of
like in um
i was more into like uh
more new wave type stuff
like david bowie and
uh
duran duran
all the all the later stuff and more
goth type stuff started to come in but i
would say you know
you change kind of rapidly when you're
that kid but i kind of had a long hair
like a [ __ ] big mullet type thing
but that was real common in in those
days yeah a lot of people it's right
around 85.
you didn't look that different then no
andrew eldridge had that from from
sisters of mercy pretty much had that
haircut
yeah pretty much pretty much i mean yeah
well it wasn't considered like
well we've talked about this before how
the mullet yeah as a uh as emblematic of
like redneck culture yeah that's uh it
wasn't like that in the 80s because you
had like new wavy looking people with
what would be called a mullet nowadays
now that would be me that was on me only
like two years later
so that was about 87.
so gotten shorter
shorter here
cut that [ __ ] shorter yeah
yeah i never uh i never went through a
metal phase i pretty much went from
childhood where i was like mostly like
listening to the beatles because that's
what my dad was into i mean i even
learned to like play piano so i could
play beatles songs and [ __ ] like that
and
then when i was 9 10 11 getting into new
wave like as soon as
mtv started
how old was i when mtv started nine
so
as soon as mtv started um
i got all in a new wave because mtv when
it first started they didn't really have
a lot of videos
uh you know from established bands so
they were kind of looking for content
wherever they could get it so a lot of
like maybe like new wave or you know
kind of bands that were more
experimental they had some video clips
and they're like hey here show this
so there was a lot of weirder [ __ ] on
there back then so i got really into
that i was like i jumped right onto that
bandwagon
um
yeah a trying to say when he was talking
about the sting album in slayer yeah
yeah that's about what he looked like so
yeah you when you were a teenager yeah
i kind of looked like
i looked fairly normal when i said but
in high school
i didn't start dyeing my hair until
later but my hair was
red i mean it's naturally
red like coppery red
but in high school i shaved half of it
off
and then i just started wearing like um
i don't know like stuff i got from
military surplus
kind of [ __ ]
trench coats and
combat boots and
then i would just every now and then i
would save up and i would buy shirts
from burning airlines you guys remember
burning airlines it was in new york in
uh no it was in new jersey
and they would send out this little
photocopied stapled
catalog
and they had all the t-shirts from like
all the weird bands from back then they
had alien sexy and they had all that
kind of stuff so if you wanted good
shirts that was pretty much where you
had to go it's not like now where you
can just go online and get whatever
shirt in the world that you want or make
your own if you would rather do that
but back then you couldn't do that so
you had to get a burning airlines and so
every now and then like whenever i got
birthday money or
got some kind of money i would save it
up and i would just buy like some
t-shirts so i just like had the t-shirt
half my half-shaved
head my combat boots
and my trench coat that i got for three
dollars at a thrift store
that's that was my high school that was
my high school career
all of that listen to bauhaus and alien
sex weed and cocktail twins and all that
kind of stuff
uh all right so you gotta talk because i
gotta go all right
during that same time
hold on that was a little bit
of that picture that i showed you of me
that was how
the sisters of mercy looked
so they kind of had that same haircut
let me show you see if i get some more
and i was a i was
i was a huge fan
okay it's also the sisters
so they just kind of had long hair and
suits with hats
other than that it was pretty much
you know
okay this is kind of like where was that
one
there was an iconic photo of them i had
this photo
of them when i was a kid and i was like
man those [ __ ] are looking so
cool and if the photo was taken right
outside
of saint andrews hall which is a place i
was hanging out at in detroit
a lot because the sisters of mercy love
detroit
and uh granthar's he's he's on the line
right now we went to high school
together in the detroit area at that
same matter of fact that photograph was
taken in michigan when i told one that i
showed you
that's the that's a picture
of andrew right outside saint andrews
hall
all right and that is 1985.
and see he's just got a leather
motorcycle jacket on and long like a
long mullet
and sunglasses and it says behind him
adults
it says detroit's the finest adult
movies on that thing behind him that's
not because this photo's been cropped
but that in that in 85
was got this [ __ ]
it's just that's aged out you can't
really see his face in this photo
somewhere because i got the glare and
it's not really
focusing on it
but it's just white it out
adriana also says jenny did you wear
makeup like susie sometimes i did if i
felt like it
but
a lot of times i was just kind of like i
always did makeup i didn't ever go to
school without makeup on for christ's
sake but
sometimes i would do like over the top
and sometimes not so much it depended on
like whatever my mood was that day
here it is there's that full
photograph
come on
trying to get this thing to full screen
but i guess it won't
what the [ __ ]
why is technology always raping me
probably because you're drunk and you're
pushing the wrong buttons all this damn
imagine
let's not trivialize rape by comparing
it to you pushing the wrong button
it just disappeared
sounds like a you problem it's just
disappeared
it's all right we saw it we saw it now i
want to show the big picture of it
it's how it wants to show the big
picture of it
because
but you can keep entertaining
keep entertaining may i well no i'm not
because then you're going to like
interrupt and i'm going to interrupt
adriana said the sisters had the best
style ever they did and it's like well i
kind of feel like wow well the reason
that they had a good style was because i
feel like it wasn't like overtly a style
you know what i'm saying
although
he kind of lost it over time and the
mission picked it up see when they broke
into two bands
that first if you like early sisters of
mercy stuff you'd like the first
you'd like the first few uh mission uk
albums they're really good
i mean obviously in the uk they're just
called the mission but over here they're
called here they're called the mission
because there was already
already a mission here yeah but the
mission was really good honestly like i
like the mission like probably wasteland
is my favorite song of theirs but
i never really their stuff to me was was
almost going to like u2 territory some
of it later on later later on yeah i
always liked sisters better even though
sisters i mean by the time like the late
80s early 90s came along
uh they started going in a more glam
metal direction which i also wasn't a
fan of although i do like vision thing
but what was that 92
that was 92 right uh yeah that was 90s
yeah that was 92. that was 90s flood
land was not a bad album no flood land's
good yeah well i think i mean flood land
is still a good album although i think i
prefer first and last and always just
because flood land has been so
if you go to a goth club i can almost i
will give you 50 dollars if you go to
like a god club and don't hear
this corrosion or lucretia my reflection
or
one of the songs off flood land they're
gonna play one of those [ __ ] i
mean it just it still happens and that
album came out in 1988 for christ's sake
when it comes to the mission this is the
album you want to get you want to get
that one because it's called the first
chapter and that sounds a lot like first
and last and always
real similar
and then like a couple albums after that
still now um
god's own medicine was pretty good but
that was like one of the first albums
that
kind of started to sound a little bit
like youtube
but i went back and listened to it
more recently and i was like yeah this
this is good i probably appreciate it
more now than i did at the time because
i kind of feel like at the time yeah
there was way better [ __ ] right um you
know i was kind of like that's a little
too
mainstream sound it had a mainstream
vocal sound to it at the time yeah and
so i didn't really like it but if i
listen to it now i'd probably like it
because i did like some of missions like
i said the earlier stuff but i was more
a sisters person yeah after after
[ __ ] the mission started getting into
the late 80s early 90s they the vocals
sounded like bono it sounded like bono
from from you too it had a sound kind of
like you two now i think they might have
been a little bit related
no you're thinking of uh
the virgin virgin prunes were cousins to
the guys yeah the guy in the virgin
princess
i think the virgin prunes and [ __ ]
the mission i think they might have
known each other so i think there's like
i think there are yeah that might have
been it might have been yeah but i mean
i'm going to say the virgin priests were
a lot better virgin prince are good done
the mission i mean because they
as far as i know like from what i know
of the virgin prunes uh they kind of
like stayed weird
they were goth they didn't really go
into like they did some weird action it
was like hobbit goth
although they had some club stuff like
[ __ ] uh baby turns blue
but that's a great [ __ ] song yeah was
it called baby turns blue right yeah
yeah baby turns blue yeah that's a great
song that's a great song i love that
song they don't play that at clubs now
no they don't [ __ ] play i'm gonna
request that [ __ ] you should that's a
great [ __ ] song
and that's one yeah that's one that
doesn't get played a lot like from back
in the day you used to play it at man
ran boston all the [ __ ] time i think
i heard it once or twice oh no i was at
i don't think i've ever heard it in a
club in florida give me money and give
me sex give me something give me food
integrity give me food some cigarettes
yeah
but i heard it at when i was at
drop dead festival yeah they played it
there but like i said that was more
death rock oriented so they're going to
play more virgin prince because they
were more a death rock band
but yeah they did some clubby [ __ ] too
just like 45 great but you know what i
mean spock says love your content y'all
keep it up spock's holodoc
thank you thank you very much thank you
camp guy said sounds like my mother when
she was trying to save a word document
she would call me on the phone and say i
worked on that document for an hour to
just disappear
i was not good at talking to my elderly
parents on the phone when they had
computer problems
i mean i feel like at this stage
uh if you haven't figured computers out
by now you're probably not going to no
you're going to say
yeah
i mean there's [ __ ] i can't figure out
on there too but
i mean i grew up with the [ __ ]
when it when we didn't have windows
i started using computers when i was
eight
when there were still floppy disks when
it was still apple 2e when you still had
to program all the [ __ ] yourself and
i've used computers like steadily since
then
so
i can usually figure [ __ ] out
it might take me a minute but i my goal
is to not be one of those old people
that yeah it's just like how does this
work
i just don't want i never wanted that
dad
i never wanted that to happen to me i
can figure most [ __ ] out i mean well
most of it makes sense if you grew up
with it like i did then
most of it is not and and to be honest
like nowadays it's a lot easier than it
used to be yeah if anybody if any of
y'all have any questions about any cases
or anything paranormal or true crime go
ahead and drop us something in the uh in
the comment section we're always open
[ __ ] super chats [ __ ] got
lawn mowers to pay for and rent
it's the lawnmower mandate
yeah three thousand three thousand
dollars damn lawn mower you are on the
hook well we're on the hook now yeah for
three thousand dollars well we would
have had to spend it in the long crew
expenses i know
nice [ __ ] this is husqvarna got me a
husqvarna
it was only a few hundred dollars more
with a cup holder got a cup hole they
all had cup holders they knew who they
were selling these things too they knew
where they knew who they were selling
them to got the 749 cc [ __ ] v-twin
engine in it
air cool
at least our yard isn't that weirdly
shaped yeah it's not that weird it's one
it is it's pretty much one basically one
rectangle
some angles on it
okay well in the front there is kind of
like an italy yeah do i want to talk
about anything paranormal want any ufo
stuff lately i've been getting back into
the phoenix lights and i found so talk
about sources that actually lead back to
the original source material
not the videos of the flares but the
actual [ __ ]
triangle with the lights in it i found
that
uh
i started getting into the dude who did
all the original research for it i think
he's dead now
uh and uh he did a great job i was
listening to a radio show that he put up
they have five witnesses that saw it one
of them was a cop the last one was a man
a man of your stations he wouldn't name
him and
wouldn't name him and
uh just what if you knew who this was
you know and i think it was the governor
five sidington who who was talking about
it who will remain named
yeah i'm pretty sure by the way just
like to keep from getting sued it was
governor symington i think
before he came out
and admitted to it but uh the original
phoenix lights
event
i'm convinced happened too many people
saw it too many people called in well
yeah we did a show about that right yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure every day two
people saw it thousands and thousands of
people i don't know if it was
necessarily aliens but enough people saw
that it must have been something wow
there's one witness on there that got
furious saying that there's no other way
that the thing was at least a mile
across wing tip to wingtip
and that um
one of the sighting areas that had 10
people
were in it
10 people came forward
in another area of the town that said
they were in a crowd of people each one
of them said they were in a crowd of
people that saw a certain event happen
and they were the only ones out of that
crowd that said anything only 10 of them
so only a small fraction of the people
that see these things actually reported
they didn't want to talk about them and
the weirdest event was
is that 10 people in different locations
okay but in the same general area
said they saw three
of those
chevron shaped
black triangles with lights on three of
them stack
on top of each other one one above the
other like uh
pancakes
and they saw uh military jets
come up look at it and then the three
stack
turned into a ball of white light and
then it vanished
and then and it says
nobody wanted to talk about that
and no and even even when you wanted to
go on a show those people that wanted to
go on a show the shows wouldn't accept
them they saw three of them stack on top
each other and then a ball of light
consumed by a ball of white light and
then it faded away
as a jet [ __ ] approached it
and um
this is back in the 80s
unrelated witnesses
yeah
i'm thinking
something kind of like the monolith out
of [ __ ] 2001 three of them
and they just kind of stacked on top of
each other and then just wormed hold
their worm hold themselves away
you know that's funny they're like
stacked like voltron there they stay
they said they stacked like pancakes
they stacked one on top of the other
like pancakes or like a giant they were
consumed by a ball of white light that
faded away
and they were gone
now
most scientists who were big into this
said that
really
alien technology if it was really
significant enough to be truly alien to
get here across the gulf of space
anything that their technology would it
would seem like magic to us
and that's what that seems like magic
it was something that we couldn't
really fathom
you know that wasn't really a concept
back in the
late 90s that you would really come up
with
yeah they stacked upon they stacked up
on each other like a set of pancakes and
then just vanished in a ball of light
like they wormholed away
yeah
weird
that would sound very [ __ ] bizarre
back in those days but more plausible
now
with quantum theory and stuff multi you
know already you have
people in universities saying that
there's more than one [ __ ] physical
dimension just something you just
slipped away into another dimension
weird
i don't know if i would like that
yeah if you just like one day woke up in
another dimension you're like god damn
it where the [ __ ] am i at now here's the
thing
we see something like that's a mile
across wing tip to wingtip we say well
it's a spaceship
i think that might be a very primitive
concept
i don't think it's a spaceship at all
you get something else
i think it's just a [ __ ] living i
think it's more like the monolith out of
[ __ ] 2001
a living being that is a machine that's
what i think it is
i don't think there's anything
biological in it
something truly superior
next dimension media said i've been
getting into skinwalker ranch on history
channel yeah watched your episode on it
from three years ago the other night uh
seeing you guys in the old house looked
weird yeah did it honestly well honestly
if i ever go back and like uh watch
stuff from our old house especially
before we had like all the [ __ ] painted
and decorated and good microphones and
good microphones yeah it is like really
weird yeah it is pretty good and before
we had like decent lighting and [ __ ]
yeah not that this is all that great but
it's like it's better it's better than
it was it's way way better than it was
you guys don't even get the view that
i'm getting man cause i'm seeing them
but just sexy legs and titties you're
looking good man
i got my shorts you're looking good well
i just pulled out whatever skirt was
like on the hanger and i was just kind
of like i have long ones in the short
ones you've been working out she's on
diet
she's uh building back up looking good i
rode 20 miles on that [ __ ] bike did
you yeah okay we'll get you some wind
straw and some weights i'm going on
windstraw cycle uh in a couple weeks i
don't care about that i'm just okay
that'll help you though if you want to
go that's what yeah it's so easy just
tiny tiny mouth tiny mouth to help
accelerate things yeah like i said good
for endurance
and well you know and like i said i'm
trying to like not because i'm one of
those people unfortunately that i so
much as like sniff some food and i gain
weight
so i pretty much have to it's crazy
because i watched a lot of these videos
i don't know why i'm so fascinated with
this i think i've brought this up before
i'm fascinated with
these
channels there's a whole sub genre on
youtube of people that are like you know
eat for 15 a week or whatever like feed
a family for have like however little
and from dollar tree or whatever and
they're like showing like stuff to make
and i'm like fascinated by those ladies
and so the women that are on there it's
just kind of like well it's like i ate
for you know five dollars for three
meals a day or whatever and it's like oh
it was only 1500 calories i'm like 1500
calories that's a lot yeah i can't eat
that many calories a day i will get fat
i was like i don't know like maybe like
other people are different i really envy
people that can actually like eat food
yeah i don't think i eat that and not
get fat
because i eat more than
1 1200 calories i guarantee you i will
get that yeah i don't think i don't even
think i'm eating that
and people and i've seen like people say
like oh you know 15 600 that's not
really enough i'm like [ __ ] i mean it's
probably not enough for you but it's
like if i ate 1600 calories a day i
would wave 300 pounds but we gotta
factor in like when we're doing shows
how much we're drinking
and if you drink that too but we don't
do that like one i don't drink soda i
just drink water right
um you know yeah we drink but i only we
only do this what you know once twice a
week
and the rest of the time
i drink a lot of protein shakes i try
not to eat vegetables
i don't eat breakfast yeah um because i
try to do like the 14 16 hour fast
if i've eaten the night before i think
you're doing about 900 calories probably
i yeah i think it's probably about a
thousand i try to keep it around a
thousand yeah i'm hungry but i'm not
starving
and honestly if i
just from my own personal experience
look i'm like almost 50 i've done this
before
from my own personal experience if i go
much over a thousand calories a day i
will start to get fat um i don't like it
i'm not i'm not a fan but
that's just what happened and that's
what happened a lot of people don't
understand this
some people are born with metabolisms
that do that
but
a lot which which you may have been
slightly like that from birth i don't
know if it's genetic a lot of
southerners i think it is actually
because my the whole mom side of my
family is all we're all kind of like a
lot of southern genetics are kind of
like that short and squat and they gain
a lot of weight and it comes from those
are the people that survive famines
yeah but it's like unfortunately i'm not
in a famine situation if i was right i'd
be set right but
because the south got starved out
unfortunately yeah starve got south got
starved out twice
during the civil war and also during the
depression all right so if you had a
metabolism
that was uh real good at keeping weight
on at a very low low caloric intake then
you passed that test all right i'm kind
of like that not not that i am big time
i like that
um
and i but the sad thing about it is that
i have that yeah and i also love food
and i love to eat southern food is very
fattening it is yeah okay it's also very
good but it's very fattening southern
food outside the south is called soul
food all right
it's not it's southern food black people
and white people eat the same food in
the south uh pretty much okay so
this is funny good you know my soul food
i mean this is soul food well [ __ ] i
guess i'm black because this is what we
grew up with you know black eyed peas
and [ __ ] cornbread and [ __ ] you
know
collard greens collard greens and yeah
my grandma used to make all the
suckatash
[ __ ] you know and she was [ __ ]
yeah
[ __ ] yeah
it's uh you know but anyway uh no so
anyway the uh
and then also the southerners tend to
eat a lot of sugar okay [ __ ] left to
their own devices i really try to like
not a high carb because like i said even
in my coffee i have zero calorie
sweetener i drink zero soda right all i
drink is water yeah sometimes liquor
water and you make tea with
right with zero calories a lot of
crossovers but i drink zero soda ever
it's a lot of crossover between american
southerners and mexicans
uh mexicans are the same way mexicans
are [ __ ] short
but i guess they'll [ __ ] can't wait
quickly
you look [ __ ] great
into your 20 and then you're fat and
you're pregnant
but that's what i mean you get away with
it well honestly 25 and you're fat you
pregnant i mean when i was a little kid
yeah
um
i was skinny when i was a little kid
yeah the second i hit puberty like when
i was 11 or 12
i started to chub out
yeah
you know and i don't think i ate all
that much because i wasn't like i said i
was i never was into soda i didn't like
real heavy gravy type i wasn't really
into all that
but
as soon as i hit puberty i just started
like chubbing out yeah and it's just
been like a constant struggle my mom had
the same thing it's just a constant
struggle
to just keep from getting fat and i
really really have to
watch it i can't just like eat whatever
i just can't yeah but it sucks but
the mexican mexico and central america
and the southern regions of the united
states all had a lot of famines uh
didn't matter what your ethnic
background was famines happened so
selective
selective breeding i guess you could say
by famine and uh cause certainly that's
i was thinking about that today i was
like my body just like
it hangs on to every calorie right i go
up north i feel short if i'm down south
i'm around a bunch of [ __ ] central
americans and and and southerners and me
guys yeah
like we were out and [ __ ] watching
the damn
uh sisters of mercy
band and we've got two
mexican dudes going crazy over this oh
my gosh
i don't think they spoke english they
were from [ __ ]
either mess man
into it way too way i mean which i
respect that i was just kind of worried
because i thought he was going to
accidentally like you know plug me in
the face
because he wasn't really baby mexican
goths are way into systems of mercy way
they know all about it [ __ ] it's just
his mercy [ __ ] uh tours in central
and south america they [ __ ] they'll
fill it there's a massive massive god
following it so this dude in central and
south he was yeah dude next to us in his
mind over a tribute
okay yeah
but it's the whole time it was like
funny but it's funny [ __ ] all the
little short [ __ ] fat i felt
tall around these people oh god that's
all right babe we're short too
but uh yeah like i said it doesn't occur
to me because i've i'm five foot two
five or three something like that five
six i'm a little bit taller with my
boots on but
i'm just used to being like a short ass
[ __ ] everybody's like usually
everybody's taller than me i go up to
the mexican market and i got a
restaurant right there i'll be the only
oh the only american guy in there and
[ __ ] at five six i'm one of the
taller guys in there a lot of guys are
five feet
little bitty dudes little bitty dudes
hard workers though they're working on
these farms you know and you can't help
your height really yeah i mean that's
kind of like one of those things you
can't too much about yeah and we don't
really have they're not illegal they're
all legal they're all here illegally we
got seasonal workers that come in
so uh
you know
they're not hiding or anything you know
they don't have to hide from immigration
or anything they're just
walking around [ __ ] proud i'm here
making money you know they they're
friendly real friendly
working on horse farms and cattle farms
here
yeah it's just but that's
i'm just just laughing thinking about
that
because i don't think you know what i
don't think we talked about the show
about the show that we were last
saturday yeah those guys are [ __ ]
losing it yeah that dude was and i was
like dude man go over there go stand
over there and he's like no it's okay
and then he goes back to the [ __ ] well
like i said i was worried because yeah
not because like i i respected that he
was like super into it yeah but i was
like this dude's legit gonna like hit me
right in the [ __ ] and break my nose
like without even like realizing trying
to keep him in a safe distance
without trying to get mad but i didn't
want to get mad at him you know what i
mean he was annoying me but i didn't
want to get mad because well he was
annoying me too but i was just like he's
so happy he was happy he's so happy he
was happy and it's like i didn't really
want to like harsh his buzz you know
what i'm saying because he was like
clearly like so into it yeah but i was
just kind i kept like scooching over i
was like please don't break my nose
please don't break my nose like without
and can we also talk about the person
i'm pretty sure this person comes to a
lot of shows at will's pub because i
think i saw them at oh cameraman
yeah i think i think i saw them at
the asari night show too yeah he's
ridiculous so we were kind of like up in
the front i don't know what this
person's deal is
but i've seen them there at will's pub
before i haven't seen them anywhere else
so it must just be a wild pub thing and
it must just be a live show thing
because they came to uh a starry night
as well but they were at the temple of
mercy show
this
person um
they're older how old are they do you
think i didn't look at them that close
they've got to be in their 60s 60s
um i thought it was a woman but he said
no it's a man it's a man who's
he has just like look really long like
right here i was like i said i wasn't
really looking that close he is one of
the he's uh i think what they would call
uh what do they call it
gender non-binary that'd be a good way
to put it that's the politically correct
way to put it well maybe but like he
said
non-binary decades ago well that's what
i'm saying like so i didn't really like
i wasn't looking that close like i was
like oh maybe it's a one but i wasn't
really like i was just like whatever
so biological mail what they're doing is
they they have a cell phone right
and they're filming the band which is
not weird like a lot of people do that
but what they do they come to the front
and he's like
yeah
yeah i didn't couldn't understand it and
i'm like are you trying to throw the
phone at them or throwing the vision are
you trying to get like some artistic
shot like i couldn't understand what
they were doing man was an idiot
i mean
they were filming they were like okay i
got i got a that is the good story that
you brought that one up i forgot about
phone thrower
phone and i was just kind of like look
i'm not look
whatever like you do you you're not
hurting anybody yeah but i'm just kind
of like looking at them going like what
exactly
are you trying to accomplish here
adriana says tom can someone get in
shape just using a walker well i had to
have more contacts with that are we
talking about a young person or an old
person a young person who is injured an
old person that is not in good shape
uh you know so there's not enough
information there can can a person get
in shape with a walker in general i'm
gonna say no
no
well it depends on what you mean by
injury yeah how do you define in shape
you know you talk about [ __ ] ripped
[ __ ] strong someone that made a damn
difference no no
now you talking about another person
who's [ __ ] 300 pounds and they have
to [ __ ] lose 100 pounds over the next
[ __ ] years
yeah you probably could but that's not
in shape okay i don't even consider
myself in shape
all right i'm talking i'm still [ __ ]
maybe 16 17 body fat me in shape would
be more like 10
i want to be 10. i don't want to be five
five
five percent is [ __ ] not healthy but
ten
that's abs no [ __ ] fat
really
oh no no you know i mean no little
like no pinching things i could still
pinch an edge type deal i don't want any
of that
that's in shape to me at least on a man
a woman's different
they have a different body makeup fat
looks better on a woman
um
as long as it's in the right places but
so does muscle muscle to me looks great
on a woman but it's got to be a right
amount i like big
legs
big butt
good waist it doesn't have to be super
small but a good waist
with good shoulders good boobs
nice arms you know which that really can
be maintained into your 70s
so i'm not i don't my tastes are not
unrealistic
now
could that be done in your 70s by normal
means no
no
it's going to take hormone replacement
steroids
but therapeutic doses not
competition doses a human can hold
themselves together with false teeth
canes wigs [ __ ] working out just
little tweaks here and there over time
makes a difference
it works
i'm nearly 55. i go into a [ __ ]
biker bar with dudes my age i blow those
[ __ ] away
and i'll tell you i have guys come on
boy you're in really good shape and
they're
you're older than us and you're in good
shape and they're in their
20s 30s
and i'm like thank you
i worked for it but i did the right
things you
chemistry has a lot to do with that your
blood
blood chemistry has a lot to do with it
your hormone levels
young people look good because they have
good hormone levels
when those go away you have to inject
them
and you'll look like that kind of
you know kind of you'll have a similar
shape or better
well it's always interesting to me
because like i said i guess genetically
i was one of those people that
as soon as i went through puberty like i
said i started like chubbing out so i
always hear these stories of like oh man
i looked so good when i was in my 20s
like i could eat whatever i wanted i
didn't gain weight i was like that must
have been nice for you i know i never
had that in my teenage year like i said
as soon as i hit puberty like 11 12
years old i started getting fat so um
hormones yeah so i never had that that
lovely period where you're in your teens
or 20s where you could eat whatever you
wanted you don't really have to exercise
and you still look fantastic i never had
that yeah you were i did not have that
you were kind of like a lower
testosterone females i've never had that
probably higher in estrogen and
not not real good in progesterone that's
genetics
which
that might work well in in in a in in a
situation where you were coming out of a
families that went through um starvation
like i said if i was in a zombie
apocalypse
i would own right yeah unfortunately
right now you weren't built to be around
food no you're building around yeah okay
but it's not a fun time for everyone
especially not for me yeah
there are a lot of ways to fight that
though diet exercise hormone supplements
but i mean happily the thing about it
though is like if i go a few days
eating a minimal amount yeah
the first few days are miserable
but after that you kind of get used to
it yeah and then it's not so bad then i
don't really get hungry or anything like
that
um you know i'm not like one of those
people that gets like super hangry or
anything like that it's like you know
it's not too bad you just have to like
put up with
a few day like three four days where
you're kind of like oh my god i'm dying
like i feel like i'm gonna pass out i'm
like super hungry everything like that
but after that it's fine it's fine you
can still eat
you just have to keep it
or i just have to keep it around a
thousand
under 1200 ideally
ideally because other big more than that
and i'll start gaining weight she's from
florida here that's laura lopez i think
she's 52 years old if i show you her at
30 you'll laugh she didn't look anything
like that at 30. okay and that is
hormone supplements
working out and
small
amounts or what you call therapeutic
amounts of anabolic assistance a little
bit of [ __ ] uh the right kind of
steroid certain steroids women can take
other women can't i'll show you a before
and after picture
um
hey here we go
that's the difference between 35 and 48.
big difference
yeah but the average person she wasn't
fat no she wasn't good no she wasn't fat
she wasn't fat but there's a bit not
that big of a difference but there's but
they're but the thing is that's 48
yeah but like i said it's not really
that big no that's a big difference
because the average person at 48
wouldn't if the average woman at 48
would never look like that what i'm
saying is that she had
she it's not like she was way overweight
or i mean she was in shape when she was
there yeah she was but she got older so
she got older though so she didn't have
as far to go as somebody that was but
that's not weight loss that's not weight
loss that's not what you're saying what
you're seeing is you're seeing someone
who defied age
yeah okay
48 is supposed to look pretty goddamn
[ __ ] up for the average woman
now that was not natural no way hormone
supplementation and and
small amounts really she doesn't lift
that much i've seen a routine she
doesn't lift that heavy
but that's hormones
48
you guys can attest the average woman at
48 looks nothing like that the average
woman at 48 looks like those 48 year old
women at [ __ ] the oasis
that's the average
and that's really not genetics she's had
two kids
it's that's [ __ ] hormones
and working out that's not normal
there's nothing normal about that
well i'm a little bit older than her
you're older than her
yeah
but she's 53 now she still looks like
that
i found a video the other day that was
uh recommended to me it was from a
channel that i don't subscribe to but it
was like a good channel and it was
called did people used to look older
because this is something that we used
to talk about
a lot and they and he came to the
conclusion he's like
yes and no he's like some of it might be
just perception because of like the
hairstyles and the clothing and stuff
like that because they said you have to
think that
the people like what they wore
back then for young people
now like they kept wearing it like all
the time so now we associate that with
like old people clothes because that's
what they were when they were young and
that was a long time ago so he's like so
it might be like 50 that and 50
you know our nutrition is better we
don't smoke as much we don't drink as
much we don't go out in the sun as much
like or if you go in the sun you at
least wear sunblock so it's like we are
a lot more aware of health of health and
like things that make you look older
which they weren't back then so it's
like so he kind of came to the
conclusion that it was like 50 50. but
it was like a good video he kind of went
off on some tangents but it was like
really interesting i thought
no but it's just called do people
did people look older like back or
something like that that amazing
[ __ ] right there is the arnold
before arnold that's steve reeves
and i believe this photo was probably
taken in the very early early
60s or maybe late 50s
all right
is that
attainable naturally
[ __ ] no
no that's testosterone it's testosterone
and maybe very early steroids but not
very much okay that dude some a quart
a half or one third the size of arnold
schwarzenegger he's not that big he's
just it's just the
it's just the um
uh
the the definition and the like that's
what he that's what he really looks like
it's really not extreme well i mean
steve reeves isn't a bunch of hercules
he's in a bunch of hercules
but that's nowhere near the size or the
extreme level of say what arnold was and
arnold was kind of considered small for
bodybuilders of today
but even back then they could achieve
things
you know they knew about it but only
some people knew about it
so if you ask me
that's the archetype
you don't want to be any bigger than
what are we looking at nothing no same
thing
same goes same same thing you stepped on
my toes steve reeves you don't want to
be any bigger than that
no bigger than that
anything bigger than that might be it
might hurt your health and he lived way
into his 70s
man my shit's empty i'll get you know
you're almost uh yeah
finished too but yeah
it's like you
know i don't know it's
just i don't know my cross to bear i
guess
uh adriana brought up lacrimosa the
german goth band yeah i've heard of them
uh they're actually really really good
um slash fred said there was a radio
station that that i used to listen to
called k-earth 101 they used to play
music from the 50s and 60s yes yeah i
like a lot of that stuff and honestly
like it's easier to like stuff when
you're
i don't know if this is true for
everybody but i kind of feel like it's
easier to like stuff when you're a
decade or two removed because you don't
like i said one you don't have the
cultural context so you can come to it
you know without any preconceptions i
guess
and for me i tend to like stuff even
stuff that i didn't like in the 80s
or 70s and 80s when i was growing up
i tend to appreciate more now because
i'm not hearing it all the time like so
it's not like over saturated so i can
appreciate it more on its own merits
rather than it having all of this
baggage around it
so
i have found myself appreciating stuff
that i really really hated like back in
the 80s i don't say i love any of it
like that i would buy any of it or
anything like that but it's like
sometimes i'll hear it on the radio but
you know what that's a pretty good song
that's pretty good even though i hated
that back in the day it's like i
appreciate it more now but i think
that's because you don't hear it ever
every day i just think that's
why um
next dimension media said someone on
facebook asked what the phrase kojak
with the kodak means man i feel old now
well i probably feel even older than you
because i don't i mean i can
extrapolate what that probably means but
i don't think i've ever heard that
phrase before
maybe i'm like really out of it i don't
know
i don't know
uh camp guy says uh
tell me about that t-shirt i'm presuming
you're talking about tom i can't wear a
muscle shirt i'm an ectomorph so my arms
are not that beefy yeah i mean ever
since he started working out it's like
all he does is wear the muscle shirts
now like every time we go out he's like
always wearing muscle shirts
but that's like one of the newer ones
that we made those carolco ones
and let's see
man i feel like i'm like way behind with
the
chat
i feel like i'm way behind with the chat
oh i wanted to like address this a
little bit dom the bomb says and i think
um i think he left because i think he uh
went to bed because it was very late at
night where he was so my cousin used to
tape the top 10 every sunday in the uk
back in the 80s she made sure to pause
the tape between the adverts to skip
them
yeah i mean me and my friends used to do
that
um we couldn't afford to buy all the
albums but like sometimes they would
play good [ __ ] on the radio so every
time like a good song came on the radio
you'd always have like a tape in there
like prepared
and so like as soon as you
you'd push play and record and then yeah
like a lot of times i used to make
mixtapes for a lot of my friends back in
the old days because that was like the
music dork back then so i would always
kind of like make mixtapes it was so
much better when like
when i was able to like buy cassettes
and buy cds like in the 90s and then you
could actually make tapes with that
didn't have
ads on them
we would like cut off the [ __ ] like
where the ads were so you know that was
nice
what's she doing he's in the tree in the
bowl
just so i can with her feet up and then
she's got her hand like that she's just
licking her hands
and then look at it just
it's just funny you know what i mean
that little baby she's [ __ ] does all
kinds of funny [ __ ] she's looking at me
like what what are you doing in a bowl
well she likes the bowl yeah it's little
it's a little fuzzy bowl she sleeps in
it's exactly spooky size last night i
was looking camping out in the man cave
listening to uh old art bell stuff and
stuff and listening to well i was
watching rip tracks i was watching and
falling asleep yeah
about the [ __ ] phoenix lights
and i'm up on a little [ __ ] army mat
in my [ __ ] little thing my little
cake oh my cake he goes in a little
tent and uh
poogie comes up and lays on my arm and
looks at me why are you leaving out here
not hearing that she's just so yeah
we're talking
yeah i'm drinking tea and [ __ ] she's
looking she'll she'll look at my tablet
i'll put my tablet up and i have a
couple of little [ __ ] soup cans
behind it like [ __ ] because i have my
[ __ ] rations and [ __ ] have a suitcase
up like propping it up you're prepping
her and she'll look
and she's looking at
the faces talking
she can see him look at those tiny
pieces
and i'll put it in her ear and she'll be
listening and looking at it and she'll
look at me i heard him talking
and then and then she'll look back on it
like that and she'll be watching it like
that and she's hearing him talk and then
she looks at me because i hear him
talking
i'm telling you man i just didn't think
the animals were that smart
that cat is a trip a [ __ ] trip
put the earbud in the cat's ear and
she'll listen to it she'll lean into it
she absolutely does
and looking at the screen she absolutely
does understand she understands what's
going on what's going on and what you're
saying to her i don't think she
understands english no but she knows but
she understands
the the idea that you're trying to
convey
big time i mean like
you would have to be an idiot to like
not think that
yeah if you were around her every day
she absolutely knows what you're saying
to her
i don't think she knows what the words
mean well now she does know what some
words mean because i've had to sp i have
to spell things because if i say the
word
she'll be like
like she knows what that word means so
i've started to like spell things
if i don't want her to know what i'm
talking about
so she does know that but
from the tonier voice
uh from the look on your face she
absolutely does know what you're talking
about
she jumped up on the bed at like what
time was it i feel like it was like 6
30.
and i had actually because you were
camping out in the man cave i was
watching riff tracks
the rift tracks i watched like this was
one i hadn't seen before
it was one called the bride and the
beast
it was not directed by ed wood but it
was written by ed wood
what a weird [ __ ] movie this was but
you know how ed wood is just kind of
like you know how in the movie edward
the tim burton what he's like i can make
a whole entire movie out of the stock
footage um
that's like not a it's a joke but it's
not a joke because this movie
was essentially
the whole like second half of it was
almost 90 stock footage
and people reacting to said stock
footage yeah but the weird thing about
it was like the first part of it was
about this woman
and
she
i don't know what year this movie came
out i'd never heard of it before but
this woman she just married lance fuller
who was also in like a bunch of other
shitty 50s sci-fi movies like the sheet
creature and stuff but he was in this
too and he was just his bland
no no hate on lance fuller he's a nice
guy i'm sure um but
he buried this lady
and she had this weird thing where well
he had a gorilla
in his basement as one does
like in a cage
and she was like
vibing
with the gorilla
and then there was a thing like maybe
she used to be a gorilla in her past
life
okay
and then they hypnotize her and she's
talking as though she's a gorilla but
then they go to africa
and then they get chased by a tiger
which has nothing to do with a gorilla
and i don't really understand like where
it was going and then i fell asleep but
you know what i mean so i don't so i
don't know if the gorilla tiger uh
paradigm was resolved but i don't i
don't get it but like i said edward
wrote it so don't expect it to make any
sense but the rifftrax version is very
funny and it's actually like on to be if
you want to watch it for free that's
what i was watching it on but yeah so i
was watching that
and i fell asleep i think i woke up one
time to go to the bathroom but like you
were still in the man cave because you
stay up all night
it seems like well sometimes i'll fall
asleep early sometimes i'll be up till
like three
yeah because sometimes i'll wake up
because i usually wake up around two
yeah
three to like go to the to go to the
bathroom and then like a lot of times
i'll hear like you're still awake yeah
and i'm just kind of like man i'm glad
he's not in here because he would have
woke me up sometimes i'll fall sometimes
i'll actually fall asleep at midnight
and then wake up around two
okay because what i'm listening to and
pookie [ __ ] with me so i'll wake
right back up yeah so it's a lot of
broken sleep happening but i like it i
don't care i mean no i have that to you
but well i mean normally
if you're in the room
then usually i'll wake up early because
you're snoring or moving around or
something like that
but
even if you weren't there like even if
you're not there i usually wake up
around two yeah because i have to go to
the bathroom i could [ __ ] see i'll
try to get back into bed at like six and
try to take my drink away oh that's fine
okay i'll try to wake up at like six and
try to get laid and then not gonna me
and jimmy i gotta hold on because
then he walks away
but see because i
like i said like he pretty much he'll
stay up like half the night until like
three or four in the morning like
listening to youtube or whatever and i
can't do that because i wake up
naturally like as soon as the sun comes
up 6 30 7 o'clock i'm awake yeah uh and
i'm just like well i got to get up and
get to work
so i got to answer to adrianna about
stuff what's that okay
adriana all right she's saying that
she didn't know that they did stuff back
in the 50s she thought that all that
hormones and steroid type stuff happened
in the 70s with arnold and that was
what's called the golden era all right
that the golden era that you're talking
about in the 70s happened down at
gold's gym
muscle beach california outside venice
all right
my mom went to high school venice high
where they did
grease you know the grease movie my mom
went to that high school um
what had happened was in the during the
golden era
rich guys from california invested a
bunch of money into mexico
because the laws are a little bit
different and they made some [ __ ]
laboratories down there to make steroids
and they would hang out at gold's gym so
the doctors would be
making steroids in mexico and hanging
out and working out in the gold's gym
along with arnold and all these guys
these guys selling steroids to them and
then they would take them okay so the
doctors took their own steroids
so a lot of these classics you know
arnold
sylvester stallone
frank zane
some of them claim to be natural but no
okay
um
built on mexican steroids mexico's got
real good
laws over-the-counter laws they don't
have to worry about doctors or laws
like you know restricting any of that
very open you know what i mean you take
care of yourself you're gonna take this
then you take the risk and know how to
take it that kind of [ __ ]
um but no they were all the 70s guys
were all built on mexican steroids from
good
laboratories that they had down there
it's not difficult to make as long as
you know how to know what you're doing
and
mexico made a lot of money
okay
off of [ __ ] gold's gym that [ __ ] went
worldwide
uh mexican steroids are [ __ ]
world-renowned
uh it's over the counter there karl
skoga a lot of stuff i've used it's a
lot of their over-the-counter stuff it's
great
uh their testosterone is good anyway
it didn't start in the 70s by the 70s it
became widely available on the open
market there's a lot of mass production
of it
there's a lot of controversy about when
it started
it was known about
in the 20s
the testosterone molecule
some people surmised that it [ __ ] like
that was available in the 30s especially
the late 30s with super soldier programs
all that captain america [ __ ] super
nazis and [ __ ]
might have had something to do with the
synthesis of testosterone and things
like testosterone
but definitely by the 50s it was out
there did the average person know no
no but bodybuilders knew uh and athletes
knew about it
they didn't quite make it the same way
but no it was out there it was it's just
that it wasn't quite as good it wasn't
as specialized until you started getting
into the 50s the 50s they knew it wasn't
commonly available though
you had to know the right people
and it was very underground and real and
they didn't really know what they were
doing they were just surmising
it was experiment human experimentation
you can't really get into the [ __ ] oh
yeah that dude is now a lot of dudes
would be huge they're claiming to be
[ __ ] 100 natural [ __ ] [ __ ] if
he impresses you he's not natural
something happened
he's taking supplements that's what
they're calling it
and
testosterone supplementation at least
dudes that are big into this [ __ ] go
back to the 1800s
to be sure if somebody was natural okay
because that and even they knew you know
were they eating a bunch of balls and
testicles that came off of [ __ ] bulls
because you
yeah they were doing weird [ __ ] because
that dude was fascinating even in the
late 1800s they knew about testosterone
and they were trying to get it they were
trying to get more of it into a demand
system and uh
were they taking bull testicles or rat
testicles or dog testicles that came out
of the veterinary when they were
clipping dogs you could take something
like that and [ __ ] blend it up and
put it into a centrifuge and [ __ ]
maybe separate it and try to find an
area that yeah that's testosterone drink
that
or inject that
would it have worked we don't know but
they were trying stuff like that
um
because there's this whole thing about
testosterone suspension where they were
taking that stuff and trying to
the the main problem is aromatization
the testosterone
compound as a molecule would not hold
itself together for very long
in a in a liquid substance that you
could inject into yourself
or eat it would your your [ __ ]
kidneys would [ __ ] take care of it
probably wipe it out
but there are some people that think
that they look at some old photographs
of dudes in the early 1900s and they're
going no way
nah that's the signs of androgen use
but nobody really knows
but by the time the 50s had rolled
around yeah it was out there well i mean
the thing about it that
i don't know i think people know it
nowadays but i think people didn't know
it
uh you know back in the day like back in
the early to mid 20th century
anybody that was like a celebrity of any
kind it wasn't just like hormones or
anything like that but plastic surgery
there was all kind of like tricks
nobody looks like that
normally no
i mean the thing about it is that even
everybody that's on camera nowadays
they're on [ __ ] a lot of them well and
the thing about it they're modified i
mean even if you're not on anything
you know
if you're a woman even if you're a man
like you got makeup on you got like
[ __ ] like everybody does stuff to
look better yeah yeah and it's like
photographs yeah you can totally
photoshop them
so it's like unless you can like see a
person in person like what they actually
look like with zero makeup on with zero
cg like you don't know what that person
looks like the 1970s and especially the
1980s [ __ ] steroids when steroidal
compounds became a [ __ ] um
a taboo subject there was like oh you
take steroids oh my god but that was
kind of an ignorant
reaction to people who don't understand
exactly how they worked and what the
dangers were
and what was happening okay
so most people that were on them would
never [ __ ] say that they were on them
well it was just kind of like plastic
surgery i feel like a lot of people
didn't want to say that they had had
plastic surgery even though they had
clearly had plastics yeah there were
right ways to do it and wrong ways to do
it and the average civilian only knew
about the horror stories
and i i met a dude [ __ ] a couple
years back [ __ ] black dude we were
talking about the [ __ ] he had no he goes
arnold schwarzenegger was on steroids i
just started [ __ ] laughing and arnold
schwarzenegger ate [ __ ] anavar pills
like candy and he injected a bunch of
[ __ ] testosterone deca de rabalen
[ __ ] winstrol and deanna ball he did
a lot of that [ __ ] and he was doing it
from a teenage years
which is not good for you it'll [ __ ]
your heart up over over long periods of
time especially when you're young just
because you're not meant built to weigh
that much your heart was not built to
pump that much blood through that many
blood vessels and capillaries through a
body that massive
it's harder on your heart to pump blood
through a 230 pound body of pure muscle
than a 300 pound body of fat
it'll [ __ ] [ __ ] you
it'll [ __ ] your valves up because it's a
lot of pressure that's a lot of [ __ ]
blood vessels you got to pump it through
and muscle's very hungry for calories
and blood and [ __ ] it's just real hard
on you you can't get that big and not
pay for it especially at an early age
well that's supposed to be at a long
distance run to the age of 80. it's just
you're you're not gonna make it i mean
there's a significant percentage of
bodybuilders who die oh yeah they die
they die young because of that they're
getting too goddamn big it's not the
drug it's the size yeah they just get
too [ __ ] big too fast your heart
can't your heart can't do it can't deal
with it yeah
like you said
uh it's not good to be like hugely fat
either but
being hugely fat is easier being hugely
fat is actually easier on your body than
being hugely difficult it's hugely
[ __ ] muscular and huge and you got
big quick
you're just not gonna make it that's why
those dudes [ __ ] they all had to back
off of that [ __ ] once they got old yeah
they were dropping dead in like their
40s and stuff you just can't do it now
after the after andreno pause
which is like male menopause after that
you don't have enough lifespan yet to
really worry about it you can do [ __ ]
just
keep it reasonable you'll actually live
longer you'll be like that 70 year old
chinese guy who looks just like me looks
like he's 50. my favorite is 73 stronger
than me
competing
because he did that [ __ ] later in life
he's you know well and i feel like the
best thing is like don't overdo it don't
do overdo anything right just like you
can do what you want just like just
chill out about it understand it do
everything in like moderation right
moderation now
is that arnold schwarzenegger no the
[ __ ] was extreme from an early
age uh same with uh uh [ __ ] um
uh uh stallone i love stallone i think
he's a great guy man he beat himself up
with that [ __ ] pretty early he's looking
rough but i think a lot of that was
hcg and that's uh
uh yeah human growth hormone
human growth hormone can distort your
face and his face got slightly distorted
but he fixed it but he was doing that in
a time when they thought that human
growth hormone was better than steroids
it's not okay steroids is a lot and
steroids is just testosterone it's just
a modified testosterone without all the
negative side effects of high levels of
testosterone so you can put a lot of
steroids in you
get [ __ ] big without all the bad side
effects of putting a lot of testosterone
you want a little bit of testosterone or
more than an average human and then some
steroids you'll
but a normal amount
you know don't overdo that
you'll you'll turn out testosterone will
absolutely make you act like a complete
douche made her mean as [ __ ] for a while
well that's what i'm saying well it
makes dudes mean to [ __ ]
and i'm already mean as [ __ ] i don't
need more of that
i don't need more of that women take one
tenth
of amount of demand i don't need more of
mean producing there was a couple of
times where a couple times were kind of
experimented with a little bit higher
than than ten percent
or one-tenth and she got mean
so she went down well the thing about it
okay i don't know if you know like i've
told you this before i don't know if you
know this but it's like i'm pretty much
i'm an angry person i'm a mean person
but it's like a lot of the times
i keep it
yeah contained yeah she got very mean
but if you guys give me some [ __ ] if you
give me some of that [ __ ] yeah
then that's gonna like i'm just gonna be
like [ __ ] it i don't care yeah she's
trying to boss me around and i'm gonna
be like
oh well i will absolutely watch it
get me getting me but that time passed i
didn't [ __ ] hold it against you
because i knew and it was like yeah i
know what you're talking about because i
still want to boss you around though
because it's like well
well you have a thing where it's like
you always like to boss me around and i
don't like to be boss around you just
think i'm bossing you right now no you
are yeah you do
you are a very bossy person and i don't
like i don't like that we're both bossy
that's what i'm saying
so i'm just like well that's what i mean
i think in a lot of ways like i'm a lot
more chill about it yeah but
i really
really ever since i was a child i do not
like being told what to do i do not like
authority figures i don't like so
anybody that tries to make me do
something i'm like nope absolutely not
i'm just like very resistant to being
told what to do i'm like i know what i
gotta do i'm gonna do my own [ __ ] so if
you try to tell me like what to do i get
even if i don't fight with you at the
moment right i store it as resentment
right so it's like that's that's kind of
like my whole thing so it's like it's
not so much that i'm bossy overtly right
but i'm like covert bossy okay all right
hold on let me let me finish up her her
answer and then that's it
the difference between performance
levels
of these kind of drugs and then just
a [ __ ] um
and therapeutic okay levels are very
different like a dude that's trying to
[ __ ] win olympia
and be one of the biggest [ __ ]
in the world okay
he might be taking a bunch of
testosterone like 600 milligrams a week
and 50 milligrams of injectable dianabol
a day
and uh another [ __ ] 30 or 40
milligrams of [ __ ] injectable deca
derablin a day
all right and that's that's a lot of
[ __ ] versus a dude who's just on
therapeutic which would be
two to four hundred milligrams of
testosterone a week
and
15 milligrams of injectable deanna ball
a day instead of [ __ ] 100 all right
but 15 okay big difference
and if he's gone something like deca
[ __ ]
pro might be taking 50 milligrams of
deca durability and a guy who's just on
maintenance or
trying to [ __ ] fight off age he might
only be taking 15 or 20
milligrams of deca durab and then the
deca and the [ __ ]
the deca and the
and the [ __ ] dianaball he might only
do that for [ __ ] two months at a time
and then be off for two months and then
go back on for two months and then off
for two months you're just supplementing
and that will make a big difference over
time but you'll never get [ __ ] huge
like a dude from olympia
oh you know what i mean for your
200 something pounds and [ __ ] it's all
muscle and
but you see what those dudes are like
when they're not competing when they're
off season they don't look that good
they look kind of [ __ ] dumpy
the way they look on stage and the way
they look just when after the
competition is you don't you can't
maintain that
you can't maintain that like i said it's
just like anything it's just like a
beauty contest it's like a beauty
contest i mean
you know if you're gonna be in a beauty
contest you're like oh [ __ ] man i gotta
starve for six weeks before i do this i
gotta like tape up some [ __ ] i gotta
like [ __ ] put this makeup on i gotta
like get all this nipped and tucked
right you gotta do all the you gotta you
know
but it's not natural nothing nothing
like that is natural nothing like health
isn't natural eating right isn't natural
working out isn't natural nothing's
really natural everything is some kind
of a supplement
if you have a good diet you work out
lift weights
that's the best for building
have hormone supplementation
bolster that with very therapeutic
amounts of [ __ ] anabolics this is not
medical advice this is just i'm just
telling you the way it is this is not
advised
i don't want to get in trouble legally
and everything is [ __ ]
reasonable
and you're doing this at a place in your
time where you're after middle age
you can extend your life yeah and the
quality of your life you don't have to
go overboard yeah you're not burning
yourself up with this [ __ ] yeah you
don't have to let go overboard just get
some exercise don't eat too much
eat some healthy [ __ ] high protein low
carb you know what i mean it's like you
don't have to kill yourself right but
you know to look okay like you know i
kind of feel like people
even nowadays people are kind of like oh
they want to look like celebrities and
stuff but i was you know
those people have nutritionists and
trainers national people and a lot of
the they don't look like that when
they're not in a movie and that's
very very difficult to maintain and
nobody would want to live their daily
life yeah looking like that all the time
because it's too
hard like your life would be
on which individual person you're
talking about so they're more extreme
than others that's what i'm saying uh in
general everybody you see in the mcu or
in the [ __ ] uh any of the superhero
movies oh they're on [ __ ]
well not only are they on [ __ ] but
they're also on like super restrictive
diets
they're also on very very restrictive
like uh training regimens and stuff like
that that most normal people would not
have time for
or
want to do necessarily because like i
said it doesn't sound like a fun time no
if you want to extend life and look good
and you need effort it's and me be
coming out of a military background and
i'm basically born and raised out of a
military academy
i have to be in training at all times i
was always a professional athlete
of some sort or another
[ __ ] being in combat units from 101st
airborne division
[ __ ] second id
up in [ __ ] uh korea on the dmz
anything i was doing contract-wise after
my military career of doing a
paramilitary career i was a pro athlete
even though it wasn't as sometimes it
wasn't as rigorous as others but in
general i'm selling my body to other men
like a [ __ ] or a prostitute
the two you are a whole fashion yeah
oldest professions are [ __ ] [ __ ]
and soldiers i like that you said it
instead of me yeah [ __ ] and soldiers
are the oldest professions of the world
and they're all selling their bodies to
men now for the women are doing it for
sex and the men are doing it for death
uh you're killing the enemies of the
people who have hired you yeah and uh
that's different it's the same it's kind
of like
that's a good way of looking yeah and
the horse died and we died you know
yeah because i'm going to say if you if
you're doing like if you're a sex worker
yeah yeah you can you can die too you
can die too
uh zach says so tom i'm five foot eight
and 217 pounds what would be an ideal
weight for me i was most comfortable
at 160. yeah
well it depends on what it is are you
trying to be an otter or a twink or a
bear or a [ __ ] what are we trying to
be here you know what look are you going
for the uh be physically fit
i don't remember how old you are i think
you're in your 30s maybe late 30s i
would always say
as the guy starts getting to his mid-30s
it's time for hrt which is hormone
replacement therapy which is 200
milligrams a week of injectable
testosterone scipione i like that one
and anthony works so too
um 1000
iu of [ __ ] hcg
also very good you shouldn't need any
estrogen blockers i don't like estrogen
blockers i like have estrogen in my
system it's neuroprotective uh it helps
with [ __ ] libido
um now i will [ __ ] my estrogen up with
some of the [ __ ] that i inject but it's
temporary when i go on some kind of
weird cycle i'll do some stuff but
that's the basic protocol and then go
and lift weights weight training is very
concentrated so it doesn't take much
just three one hour sessions a week more
or less
of weights
um it's really only four exercises
jackson's 25 25 you're a little young
going to weight training
going to weight training says i just
want to not feel like crap all the time
wait
going to weight training get your gym
membership get you one of the deluxe
memberships at a gym that involves uh a
trainer which might be about 30 bucks a
month
and it will come with a trainer and tell
them that you want to put on some mass
and some bulk do that for a year and see
how you turn out after about a year
okay
uh if you're not as [ __ ] big or as
lean as you want to be then go on hrt
and you'll trim down you'll trim up
having uh it's easier for dudes i feel
because like a lot of the stuff that
i mean women do it but i feel like it
takes more effort
like men do stuff i've heard like
seriously
i've heard like men
a little bit younger and they were kind
of like man all i did was stop drinking
soda and i lost 30 pounds i'm just like
no [ __ ] yeah
but zach i know you that would never
happen to a woman never zack i know
you're gay so we got to know what your
goals are
if you want to look good
you want to look good for guys you want
to feel good
in my opinion
as a straight male
you can't get any better looking than
steve reeves if you look at steve reeves
that is [ __ ] realistic
a a a guy of okay genetics
at your height could attain that build
naturally no
but you could get a start on it
naturally and then once you cut your
teeth in [ __ ] bodybuilding you can go
on to supplement
your testosterone levels and mess around
a little bit with anabolics not much
just some
by today's standards not very light and
it would not affect your health
negatively in general as long as you
don't have some unforeseen medical
problem but chances are no
okay
uh but no it wouldn't even wouldn't take
much to look like that in terms of like
you know anabolic-wise
it's not he he's not very extreme he's
just kind of
nowadays if [ __ ] if steve reads or
get on a [ __ ] olympia
or olympia stage or anything they
wouldn't even look twice at that dude
like nah
they would say he's not massive enough
which i don't agree with that
they want too much mass
and that mass doesn't look that good
reeves was the king of [ __ ]
aesthetics okay he had a good aesthetic
balance
and uh
if you looked like that in a gay scene
[ __ ] [ __ ] you'd run that [ __ ]
zack says i just googled reeves and that
looks kind of ooh
no well you got bad taste
well not necessarily not everybody likes
yeah muscle butt like i don't he's not
muscle bound i don't particularly he's
not muscle bound he's not that heavy
it's the it's it's the shots i mean he's
pumped up
it's it's being shot in black and white
they're trying to maximize his [ __ ]
definition
just seeing that dude walking around
he's not that extreme
no he's not but i'm just saying that
like from this point of view because and
and as we can see because you get like
very very into this kind of stuff yeah i
kind of feel like
other dudes are way more into this than
women are into this yeah well it's like
women talking about hair
so i don't talk about hair
but you're not the average woman a lot
of these average girls you know if
you're making their 20s
hair and listening to hair i mean makeup
it's like a teenage girls talking about
hair well i do like look at like hair
and makeup like stuff sometimes like for
ideas but every now and then but
normally that's not usually a thing that
i give a [ __ ] about yeah
um
you know yeah i take care of my hair
yeah but i'm not like obsessed with it
yeah i don't know i'm not overall i kind
of feel like i'm not a person that's
really obsessed with
looks yeah zach zach i know you like
daniel craig daniel craig really is only
a little bit smaller than than reeves
reeves is only a little bit bigger
i mean
because reeves worked on it more than
than craig did
craig didn't work on it that much to
look like daniel craig that'd be easy
easy but he's on junk he's on stuff i
call it junk that's not really junk it's
not it's because
jung means hair junk junk is heroin
that's really bad for you yeah don't
take care of your kids what those guys
take other you can take other drugs if
you want but don't take care right
the hormones we're talking about and
steroids are a modified hormone it's a
modified synthetic hormone to get rid of
certain negative side effects so you can
take more of them
but um
uh another [ __ ]
the stuff that those guys are taking is
nowhere it is it's actually beneficial
as long as you don't overdo it and you
know what you're doing at the right
times
i mean there's some stuff out there
that's mild as [ __ ] like anavar which
are little pills
if you're working out your test is good
and maybe you're doing some testosterone
supplements you take a little bit of
anavar you'll be fine
but see i think that's the issue i think
that's why i've never been like super
into dudes that were like super muscle
bound and stuff like that because it
seems like that's
it takes up so much of your life
that you don't really have time for
anything else you think i don't have any
time for anything else i'm just saying
that it's like it kind of like takes
over your whole entire life well it's
fun it's fun it's like anything else but
dudes are like that they're into either
one thing or another remember i was
totally into motorcycles too yeah i know
totally into guns motorcycles totally in
the military stuff you just i mean i'm
totally into things too like look i'm
totally into horror movies as well like
look if i find somebody that will talk
to me about horror movies then you'll
talk all [ __ ] day yeah same thing
well and me and demetria will do that
too which is crazy because like you know
but he wrote me this big long message
yeah about my scare salon please go uh
subscribe to my new channel by the way i
posted a video
yesterday or two days ago
about comparing
stanley kubrick's the shining with the
tv movie version of the shining which
was directed by mcharris and i made like
a 45 minute video about it and to make
sure he sent me this big long thing
because he's always asking me for like
horror movie reviews and he's like oh my
god you were like you're so like
talented and you're so like [ __ ] and
so me and him will like talk about
horror movies all day long
but
i mean tom likes horror movies
but not as much as me like i'm a dork
about it yeah like if you
know about horror movies and you want to
talk about it i will talk to you
all day long about that [ __ ] yeah for
several days right now zach
but
i don't but i don't inflict it on other
people though i mean unless they ask me
about it and then we get into a thing
and then i'll talk about it but other
than that i don't really
i'm very like self-conscious about my
dorkiness yeah you know what i mean zach
a few weeks
when we went to that [ __ ] sister was
the mercy show this is a mercy tribute
show
temple of mercy temple of mercy oh sorry
i got the shirt man it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
awesome i got a temple murder well and
also
this was the opening band the obsidian
and they were also they were quite rad
yeah that's why i bought the shirt
because i'm like man you guys kick ass
they're from miami too i think so zach
toby shows up he's [ __ ] decked out
[ __ ] in his leather daddy outfit he's
just man i've got my new i don't mean to
make you mad i wanted to work out with
you but i got a new trainer man he's
closer to me and i said dude don't worry
about it man just do your [ __ ] this and
then you'll be fine and he had a new boy
with him okay that he picked up it
wasn't grinder it was something was it
go daddy did it go when it was i
couldn't really hear like you guys were
talking and i couldn't hear him on a
damn some kind of money gay sites okay
that guy was rad though yeah i liked a
guy he was cool he was like half his age
he was he was halfway he was half
hearted yeah he was a baby i was like oh
my god
you're robbing the cradle or you're
robbing the ground it's cool though
so anyway he [ __ ]
that's all that dude wanted to talk talk
to me about is about [ __ ] um
anabolics and working out he says yeah i
want to get bigger i'm going to be you
know this and that i know i heard that's
why i wandered off yeah
so you know what i mean just some it
speaks to some people and it's and
and um
you know [ __ ] being straight i could
[ __ ]
talk to the guy more openly because
you know he knows i'm not trying to get
into his [ __ ] i'm just telling him says
no if this is what you're into then
[ __ ] yeah you need to pick up some
[ __ ] a little more mass and get this
is how you do it this and that and this
is and if you're trying to track that
kind of guy then yeah this is how you do
it all right and he was like thank you
so much thank you and then all of a
sudden he didn't want to hang out with
[ __ ]
then them two started fighting
and i'm going to try and talk to him
yeah what that was he got did he get
jealous you were talking to me the whole
i thought that baby toby got jealous
because his [ __ ] news his new [ __ ]
squeeze was talking to me so i tried i
hit him up and says dude what's wrong
man what happened [ __ ] you know
because i talked to him afterwards this
is what happens oh he's going off
[ __ ]
well i wondered about that actually
because like i said even though you guys
were talking yeah
and i was just so i just kind of like
wandered off he knew i was with you
i know that but i was just kind of like
oh my god they're talking about like
bodybuilding so i'll be over here yeah
um but you know what i mean because i
hear it all the time so i was just kind
of like
well i was kind of like
surprised because toby
yeah um you know he's our age actually a
little bit older yeah and he's very
super super picky
i don't think i can count on one finger
the times that he's come
out with somebody that he's like this is
my this is who i'm dating at the time
yeah and that was years ago yeah
remember that guy probably don't know
the best he's super super picky
my buddy needs a leather daddy i'll show
you so the fact that he was at
the temple of mercy show and he had
somebody that he was just like you know
that was like his date for that evening
and i was like holy [ __ ] i haven't seen
this for like years and years because
like i said he's super super picky
so we were like fascinated with this
dude it's like and he was young he was
like like young enough to be our kid
but he was like super cool and he was he
was really really cool and he was like
really chilly he's into the [ __ ] guy
and he was new yeah he was like new to
the god scene but he knew a lot about it
he knew a lot about horror movies he
knew a lot about all that stuff so i was
like oh my god he's like really like
[ __ ] he's he's really on the ball
so tom talked to him for a long time and
then like later on i kind of like like i
said wandered off and i was like
watching the band and talking to other
people and stuff and then like he's like
oh my god i think they're fighting
because so it's just kind of like
seriously like already like how did that
happen how did that happen that's that's
a picture toby right there
a
i'm trying to get one he was [ __ ]
decked out he was decked out [ __ ] uh
victor says didn't you all say he was
girthy like a coke can
uh yeah
yeah and i'm sure if if he's watching
he'll probably appreciate it saying that
but yeah i've never seen it like in
person but i have seen it like three
pants that's decent yeah [ __ ]
got gigantic man forgot a dick like a
damn 40s beer can well out there [ __ ]
them girls are worshiping it and [ __ ]
not only that well i don't think it's
just that i think it's just that they
can dance
one he can dance yeah he's into cool
music he's a cool [ __ ] he's in good
shape and he's just a genuinely he's
funny nice person he's a nice person
yeah real fun
he's not he's tough he's not a dick yeah
he's not a jerk he's not arrogant he's
nothing like that he's just like a a
good dude yeah
you know you can hang out with him and
he's totally cool so i think that's kind
of like a lot of the appeal also
so the i didn't know he was gay
well for a long time no he's gay and
then he told me later that's all i
didn't know he said oh yeah yeah well it
never really liked hurt yeah he's gay
he's just uh
and he's uh tough he doesn't look
zach he does date gay dudes of course
but in general he doesn't like gay dudes
he thinks that they're full of [ __ ]
he likes straight dudes
but he's kind of a
you see
i'm telling zach this all right [ __ ]
he knows
gay dudes when they're growing up their
their whole their whole uh experience
with
relationships from an early age is one
of usually a disappointment because they
[ __ ] fall in love with dudes that are
straight they don't want them so it's
heartbreak so they they start off
already kind of on the wrong foot with
everything
and then they start going out with gay
dudes and then the gay dudes kind of
[ __ ] disappoint them all right uh at
least when they're when they're guys
like toby okay because he actually likes
straight guys
all right yeah but
well the thing about it that stuff she's
like
that's not just a gay experience yeah
that's a that's a woman experience i
mean that's been my experience yeah
because you always like expect certain
things and like you start going out with
actual dudes and you're like oh you're
kind of lame oh you were also kind of
lame why is everybody lame it's just
like everybody is like disappointing
everybody
he's actually real tough
or he's kind of tough
uh and then he'll end up with these kind
of like twanks you know what i mean
[ __ ] and
he'll say something sideways to him and
[ __ ] they get insulted like they'd be
like
they're scared of him now and he's like
i'm just trying to put the dick in it
that's all you know what the [ __ ] you
know
he gets too dude he's a dude
you know
and uh i don't know it's between them
gays you know what i mean i'm watching
and i'm going damn
i feel for you bro but the thing about
it is that whoa
it's not any different from strangers
to be honest we've seen like way worse
[ __ ] like play out in straight dramas
it's all the same basically that's the
same kind of it's all the same kind of
thing
it's all it's not any different right
it's not different the thing is i was
just surprised he's got a much smaller
pond to fish that's what i'm saying
that's why it's harder because it's like
right but that's why i was surprised
because like like i said usually
uh
you know he's very picky and he's just
kind of like so i
the only time that i've ever seen him
bring a date like
for any like you know length of time was
that was years ago long time ago and he
he um
he also likes real
tough mean black dudes he likes that too
uh
he was with the black dude
but that dude wasn't tough or mean
enough for him
it's just he's like something out of mad
max you know
well
the thing about it and like i said this
applies whether you're straight gay
whatever or whatever yeah um
people are going to disappoint you yeah
i mean that's just kind of how it goes
uh
you know i here's the weird thing what's
that
years back i'm like dude you got so much
to offer a woman man these women love
you why don't you just start going with
them he's like you know i thought about
it but it's just it's just not he's not
into it
now he'll get drunk he'll get all right
yeah he loves her
but that's because i think he can't have
you
he's a i kind of feel like it might be
this it might be that he can't have you
but
i'm not sure why he likes me
particularly well it's a pr it's a
personal thing he likes you
he likes he gets drunk and then you guys
start becoming lesbians
it's like i think he likes me because
i'm a good dancer
and it's like he's drunk i'm drunk yeah
we're dancing to the same like don't
play some new wave [ __ ] and i'll be like
yeah i'm dancing with you when we're
dancing all sexy and stuff and he's just
like he likes that i they all like to
dance and then he agrees him and tried
to grab me in the ass and said wait a
minute hold on hold on he's like he's
like laughing
it's all right
he is very funny yeah he's great we love
toby
um
yeah
uh yeah so wait a minute uh tomorrow's
movie review is gonna be sick as [ __ ]
yeah tomorrow's movie review is disco
path were you the one that reviewed it
or
requested it because
yeah i finally get around to it i do i
have to say though
it's not if you're
looking for like a straightforward gela
movie it's not exactly a jolly movie
it's more a slasher movie
but it has some jealous elements so i'm
not going to like get too bad about it
so you know what i mean picture says my
type is 23 year old latino dudes with a
baby mom
oh dear
well
adriana says uh jenny if we could get to
know each other i think we'd talk of
giala films forever can you still do
giallo august honestly i have to do more
even though i did a whole month of
giallo movies
i feel like i didn't really
even i didn't scratch the surface i
didn't scratch and i know i've done some
jelly movies on my on the regular show
but
man i need to get more there's god
there's so many and there's so many
there's a lot that i've seen
but that i haven't like done video
reviews of you know what i mean so i
have to get into that i still want to do
house with laughing windows
i wrote a big thing on it on my blog
like a long time ago but i haven't done
a video review of it i love that [ __ ]
movie uh it's so good but
i don't know i'll get around to it i i
definitely will do probably like another
or i'll at least like sprinkle some of
them like through
the [ __ ] because
i don't know that's like my i don't know
if that's my favorite sub genre i think
my favorite sub-genre of horror is
probably like haunted house movies
um
followed by like psychological but
giallo is probably i like jealous movies
like better than
straight-up flashers
even though they're kind they share like
a lot of attributes but
there's something about jl movies that
i'm i don't know there's i'm just really
into those
but
i don't know and that's kind of what
happens like i
if i find somebody else
that knows a bunch of dorky [ __ ] about
horror
like because sometimes like uh our firm
brian
who uh
photograph who did that photograph that
we showed earlier of uh jenna laura
at our house because he comes to our
house for parties like to do the photo
shoot shoots and stuff demetrius is
excited man he thinks the [ __ ] whole
porn shoe is going
well you know you know how you guys do
you try to talk about that
they talk about that it's funny because
talking to each other the man about
watching are talking about and like we
don't even know what's going on yeah
they're they're like already talking
about their engineering stuff and we
don't even know what the [ __ ] going on
they haven't introduced the concept to
us bubble bath and costumes they haven't
asked us if it's okay no it's just maybe
they haven't yeah male fantasies that's
what i mean they just think that they
have this whole fantasy about what's
going to happen
man me and dmitry talk about y'all
i know you do yeah we talk about you and
jen the two gents we're like looking
juicing what have you said about me what
do you say about me
oh over the years you want me to tell
them
sure okay
whatever yeah we were going to know
we were going to [ __ ] line you all up
and hit it and [ __ ] and then well
guys that's gonna be sharing cigarettes
and [ __ ] while we're [ __ ] high-fiving
each other taking pictures
it's just you know i know that normal
you knew that one i think you told me i
would have said that a long time well i
was thinking that there was maybe
something like uh juicy that i hadn't
heard before um
yeah we're we were [ __ ] mapping out
like i said we were mapping out a whole
[ __ ] lesbian porn scene
that's also not that surprising yeah no
no they're really it's not surprising
yeah
i mean i guess like straight straight
straight guys yeah their whole fantasies
are like not that surprising no no
they're all
they're all they're all very pedestrian
so it's just kind of like when you tell
us you're like yeah okay
i was hoping for something more creative
but no okay that was basically nothing
more creative because y'all are
basically just basic [ __ ]
yelling basically [ __ ]
but yeah but like i said
you find somebody like i said our firm
brian is a photographer
he shot those photos earlier
um
yeah like he's super into well he's real
into mst also so every time there's like
some mst event going on like if there's
a rifftrax live or something like if he
comes to the club i'm like [ __ ] did you
see that like you know what i mean so we
like dork out about that but like i said
if you're gonna dork about about mst or
about horror movies man i will if you're
into it
i will talk to you all night about that
[ __ ] i don't care about how dorky it is
i don't care so
you know there's that but
because it's like like i said to an
extent
tom likes mst who's like he finds roof
tracks funny like he'll go to like rope
tracks live with me he'll watch horror
movies with me but he's not
a dork about it i'm a dork about it so
like i said if i find somebody else that
will talk to me about it like all day
long
then i'll do that but he won't so
just saying
uh toby is hot would have
would have something
with him even he's gay yet and like i
said he's not only hot but
he's just like he's a good dude he's
just like a really really cool
person what are you talking about toby
oh he's still talking to me yeah well
because adriana said something about it
what did she say about him
she said toby's hot would have something
with to do with him even if he's gay
yeah that's what i mean no you don't you
don't understand man when she when he
goes out to the clubs
dressed the way he dresses and his
dancing [ __ ] there'll be a ring of
[ __ ]
hot girls
watching him dance
because he's a good dancer well because
gonna say
95 percent of straight dudes
can't dance yeah and i was just like
can't dance i was like i was like tell
me why the [ __ ] are you gay dude
you can't help it i said like why the
[ __ ] you gay i said you got so much to
offer these women man these women are
[ __ ] crazy about you i know
yeah he does yeah i know
but this is why he's it is why don't you
just go out with one see because i got
so many because he had what they call
[ __ ] hags he's got [ __ ] like he's over
it overweight worshipers that [ __ ]
the friends is
and he's like ah the thing is is that
it's just not me i mean i like him but i
just don't like it yeah he's not like
yeah i like him but he's not really like
you know it's just not mine he can't he
can't help it yeah
they're not they're too soft you know
it was like
all right man [ __ ] they're missing
out he's like yeah they are missing out
i mean my book is arrogant you know he's
that good he's yeah they're missing out
well
i don't know like he's arrogant but he
doesn't come across funny he's funny it
is fun it's fun it's like yeah they are
girls are too soft man [ __ ] i'll punch
you right in your face
and kick you right in your team
that's not sound
danny rolling said what happened to tila
yeah what did happen to tila last we
heard of teal i mean i know she changed
her finished schedule
vanished for a while and then she she
jumped back in saying that
they were in hawaii and that uh oh
that's right remember that and that and
that they were trying to move out of san
francisco
they were having some kind of problems
with san francisco because san francisco
was [ __ ] falling apart
and uh well it's very expensive yeah and
then they went back to their vacation
and uh
that was the last we heard her but you
know what i mean [ __ ] people come and
go
from from the thing who knows maybe she
got mad over something i said or you
know i you know granthar's actually
asked who had been like which one of our
listeners had been here the longest but
i don't really know like i can't yeah i
can't really keep track like you got i
feel like you guys have been here
forever like you guys that are here
right now right victor said what
happened to david june he's still around
he actually sent me a message earlier
today yeah so he's still like listening
to the show he's still around i don't i
just don't think he's on the live stream
sandra i think maybe got mad uh when i
said that the [ __ ] uh mustache man of
the bent cross wasn't the [ __ ]
something that just came out of nowhere
that german culture was like that
so that was kind of left last we heard
of him but that is true uh he was uh
the uh the german culture was like that
uh
that wasn't they tried to blame it all
on him no well the thing about it too is
that you can't always uh attribute like
if people can't come to the live streams
you can't always attribute oh i said
somebody made somebody mad they might
have had like some life circumstances
yeah they're just going to die because
i mean victor says uh i was gone for
about two months but only because i was
working every wednesday and friday i've
been around since 2017. there's no way
enough so i never assume right like if
somebody doesn't come around anymore i
don't assume that's just because oh we
said something that made them mad i was
just kind of like because look i follow
a lot of channels too
but one i don't have time to like listen
to everybody's live streams too i don't
even have time to like watch all their
videos as much as i would
like to like even the people i subscribe
to i can't watch everything that's what
i mean i try to
but i don't really have that much time
to do it it's like i wish i had more
time to like watch all their videos and
stuff but i don't if you guys know what
i'm seeing that her legs are getting
[ __ ] so good from all that damn bike
work and [ __ ]
that's also a little bit of hormone
replacement 20 miles a day i got around
20 milligrams 20 miles
on the bike i got around 20 milligrams a
test a week
which is just basic female replacement
for post menopause and she's [ __ ]
starting to really come together
yeah starting the company starting to
come together oh no well what what yeah
of course that's sorry i'm gonna show
you
like frankenstein's monster yeah like
frankenstein i'm starting to come
together to come together i was like i
was just like in broken pieces before
but now i'm starting to come together
well you
hey i look at things like i look at
human beings like they're animals i come
from a [ __ ]
a farming background or dealing with i
know but to me
that's like hilarious because i say that
about horses she's good at where it's
coming together she's coming together
i'm not a horse i'm a person yeah but
i'm
i know that but just but we're all
animals i mean i look at myself the same
way yeah cool but like no we talking
about your definitions [ __ ]
your definition is getting good oh my
god your definition is good she's
getting starting to get the little calf
lumps and stuff and the [ __ ] little
lines right here
you're starting to get that
this is starting to come in you're
plumping out right there do you want to
eat it oh yeah oh hell yeah like in
texas chainsaw yeah this is starting to
cook you just cut that right off make a
steak out of it yeah she's looking
beautiful eat it eat it with some
onions maybe something like that every
time he starts we're going to the club
every time he starts talking like that
i'm just kind of like
i kind of feel like maybe he's cannibal
he's okay we're going to that club we're
going it's all me we're going to the
club
it's all me we're yeah we're going to
the club that's all i am is me you're
going bare-legged and then boots with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] badass [ __ ] skirt
you're going to impress people
you're getting there you're getting
there look at this [ __ ] look at that
okay hang on
is that seriously all you care about tom
no
no it's everything
what do you mean is that all i care
about that's all you ever talk about
that's all you ever talk about
oh yeah
yeah
is that really it's not what are you
talking about i don't talk about that
all the time just eat it then i'm gonna
eat it
cut it off and eat it
fry it up with some onions
i might have i might have a piece also
yeah
about you if i can um
after the show i'm going to make
something to eat uh i can't eat anymore
i already told you that
because you hit your caloric [ __ ]
yeah because while you were at lowe's
for hours and hours and you made some
[ __ ] i already ate some [ __ ] and then
you came back and without asking me yeah
made me food yeah well that was wrong so
that yeah but that went over my calorie
thing so i can't eat anymore that'd be
okay you've been good i can't eat
anymore you've been good be all right
if you would have asked me let's see
look at that i would have said i ate
already please don't make me anything
but you asked me
i mean you didn't ask me so you just
made me food and i thought you were
hungry i didn't think you'd eat no of
course i did so you're sneaking food i'm
not snaking food you were just gone for
hours and hours
you were gone for hours so i was like
well [ __ ] it i'm just gonna like have
some [ __ ] ramen noodles or something
so i just like ate that and then like
you got back a couple hours later and
she was like hey here here's some food
i'm just like i ate already but okay
that's funny adriana's [ __ ] looking
at toby's ear how hot are you that's but
yeah he is yeah the girls like him
daddy [ __ ] built like a [ __ ]
40 ounce beer can he don't have that
[ __ ] [ __ ] wearing them damn tight ass
pants and that [ __ ] [ __ ] wrapped
around his [ __ ] leg like that and the
girl's sitting there he's dancing
they're drooling looks like a 40 amps
beer can with a [ __ ] apple on the end
of it
[ __ ] bad like i said i don't
even know if it's so much that i just
think it's the fact that
he actually has rhythm and he actually
can dance really well
because like i said 95 of white dudes
sorry
can't dance
they have no rhythm yeah but they're not
in the dude they're not clubs though
they're not in our club though well even
most small percentages even some a small
percentage like goth dudes can't dance
but
most dudes can at least approximate yeah
they can put up dancing or at least they
know that they can't dance so they don't
attempt it yeah i kind of feel like the
main problem
comes with
dudes that are like they have a few
drinks in them i can dance and then they
get on the floor and i'm like what are
you even doing yeah what is this that's
not just white dudes though man that's
[ __ ] mexican dudes too because that
mexican dude [ __ ] he couldn't dance
that dude [ __ ] sisters of mercy
[ __ ] i don't even know if i'd call
what he was doing dancing
he was mostly just gesturing yeah he
expressed toward the band yeah
revoked his mexican card he says no you
can't you can't have it because mostly
like what he was doing he was kind of
dancing but mostly what he was doing was
just like yeah
he was doing some impressionistic [ __ ]
it was that kind of you're the man like
it was like you're the man but like 100
yeah it was like that so it's like
that's not
exactly dancing
if you're like just at a club there's no
band playing and there's a there's music
playing and people go out and dance like
i'm not casting dispersions like i said
on people that can't dance like because
i know that there are some people that
maybe genetically um don't have any
rhythm
this is crazy my ex-husband
uh he very famous
not famously but famously in my mind
uh couldn't dance
and he asked me he's like well i don't
understand like how do you so i was just
kind of like do you hear okay so i was
like so the song is on i was like do you
hear the beat dude dude or whatever the
b was of the song he's like i i don't
understand what you're talking about he
did not understand
the concept yeah
of
beat and rhythm yeah i was like dude all
you have to do
do some cool [ __ ] like nothing too
egregious
but do some cool [ __ ] to the beat or to
the rhythm of the song and it'll look
pretty good like it might let but you'll
look like competent at least
and he had no idea what i was talking
about what are you even talking about i
was like dude do you hear that yeah
no he didn't hear that no i couldn't
hear it so i was just kind of like
well you might have some other that was
whales man
whales i saw other welsh people dancing
they could dance away a couple of years
i'm just saying it's like i'm not sure
because some people may i don't know
maybe they have like some kind of
problem but it's like a couple weeks all
you got to do
yeah
you just got to do [ __ ]
to the beat yeah
it doesn't matter what you do is
jezebel he could dance that's what i'm
saying
from wales yeah he could dance i've been
to wales yeah you can dance
i lived in wales yeah they're not all
rhythm
deficient rhythm
that i thought it was weird because i
was like it seemed very rudimentary i
was just kind of like okay listen to
this whatever the song was let's say it
was like it was new or blue monday let's
say with that that sort of one i was
like okay now listen to the beat do you
hear it dude
like do you hear that
yeah and he just like kind of looked at
me like i don't understand what you're
talking about he didn't understand what
i was talking about yeah and i was just
kind of like as long as you do something
on that beat
then it'll look okay right it might not
look great but you'll look okay all
right so
uh what else you guys want to talk about
is there anything that's been on your
mind anything we've had on recent shows
uh we're uh available [ __ ] to um
answer any questions when it comes to
what have we talked about recently we
talked about the damn everything and
we've been talking about everything we
talked about well on the wednesday show
we talked about the british premonitions
the premier missions bureau and about
the abraham disaster speaking of whales
we also talked a little bit about the
apparatus yeah as well uh what else
which i was there at that cemetery we
talked about [ __ ] um james bond and
the double 07 series lately we could
talk about that um oh don't even get him
started i'll get started on that [ __ ]
yeah
i just i still can't believe that they
won't let my boy be
be james bond he's still sad that tom
hardy is not gonna be tom hardy but
maybe he will maybe it'll surprise us
i'm thinking it's i'm thinking it's it's
it's such a [ __ ]
maybe it's like sex i think it's a psy
i can't we love tom hardy yeah i can't
understand why tom hardy is not it's not
double seven
but he wants to do it well you look on
the bright side yeah if he's not
w7 then he will have opportunities to be
in lots of other cool movies yeah oh
another [ __ ] venom movie or it's a
win-win i gotta get the venom movies on
blu-ray it's a win-win so you know what
i mean yeah um
it says they save rhythm as a dancer i
mean like i said i know that some people
are maybe
thank you very much thank you very much
victor
thank you victor travis the chimp what's
your name travis the champ oh that was a
champ that had had they thought it might
have been a human z
with a little head do you know what i
think we should do a whole show about
you animal human hybrids
no well not so much but about like um
can we talk about like the chimp that
was raised alongside the human baby
remember like in the 70s when everybody
was kind of like well chimps kind of
like which they kind of are like kind of
like humans and they raised them
alongside kids
and
then when they got older they started
like tearing people's faces off and
stuff like that but like you know what i
mean yeah because that's what happens
because they're chimps but for a long
time like before
chimps before they're about eight years
old
they are actually a lot like human
children you can treat them as such and
actually in a lot of ways they're much
much smarter than human children yeah
puberty kicks in and that's a wrap but
then after well not so much for the
females but for the males that's it um
yeah once you get to have a mailchimp
and it hits eight years old yeah um
you're gonna have a bad time he's gonna
start like tearing your arms off [ __ ]
but females better but
uh in a lot of ways like it's really
interesting seeing because i've read a
bunch of books about like nemchimsky the
very famous like chimp that was kind of
racist human so that might be like an
interesting show to do too actually
i'm not sure if that's sensational
enough though
yeah but there's a lot of cases of that
yeah
there's a lot of cases of that and you
can
i don't know if it has to be necessarily
sensational but it just like brings up a
lot of interesting questions about
um how similar like humans and chimps
are at least like um in the childhood
era because like i said you raise kids
and chimps alongside each other up to a
certain point okay very very simple
travis the chimp
uh was raised like a kid and then it
tore the lady's face off in there that's
yeah that's what i'm saying um yeah yeah
i mean you had other ones like i said
like nimchimski who i wrote a whole like
read a whole book about
but there were a lot of chimps yeah
that's what i'm saying like in the 70s
that were raised alongside humans tammy
says that i need to watch lawless uh
that has tom hardy in it i don't know
which what that yeah i've heard about
that it might be good
what's lawless about it's a series right
i don't know
is it a series or a movie i can't
remember but yeah so
i read a book about
i think it was nemchimsky and he was the
one that was actually raised alongside
kids and he was like in a lot of like if
you saw like sesame street like back in
the 70s and stuff like that if you saw a
chimpanzee it was probably it was
probably him
but once he got to eight years old and
started getting to a point where it's
like hey i could tear your arms off they
had to like you know send him out to
like a
chimp like [ __ ] you know
camp i guess you want to call it uh
where he could be with other chimps
because he couldn't be around humans
anymore because he was getting too
aggressive
but up to that point
um
not that much difference between the
chimps and the humans and the chimps
were actually kind of like acting a lot
like humans in the sense that
if you raise them alongside humans they
would do human [ __ ] that it's just kind
of like uh they would bust out of their
cages in the middle of the night and
it's like i'm gonna go to the fridge and
get a beer yeah and then i'm gonna go
sit and turn the tv on and watch tv and
they would like drink a beer and like
watch tv just like a person
and it's just like
if you raise them like that that's what
they would do because they'd just be
like oh they do that's that's what they
kind of like knew to do but yeah so i'm
i've always been like really fascinated
buy because i'm always like um i'm kind
of a dork about
uh the science behind like
evolutionary biology like human
evolution stuff like that so i'm always
kind of like really interested in like
the similarities between
human and ape
behavior i've always been really
interested in that so i've read like all
like france de wall stuff like he's a
primatologist and i've read like a bunch
of stuff about
uh you know chimps that were raised as
humans and stuff like that so i'm like
really really into that
so that actually might be a really good
show because i actually kind of know a
lot about that topic okay so yeah that
might be something i mean i don't have a
pen there's a pen over there it says
give me that pen and that paper right
there and i'll write that down i'll
actually put that in the poll like for
paper
yeah it might be too late it's too late
to put in the poll for today but i will
put it in the poll for next week
because
i would like to do a show on that i
think that would be like really
interesting
do i have any spare paper
this one's kind of scary there's not too
much on it i just need like a little
space
uh chimps raised as humans
including travis
i'll just write travis
danny asks also jenny is there any
chance that in the future you would
review the the latest texas chainsaw
massacre film that came up we have that
wait no the latest one the latest one
that's not the latest one that we have
which is which is the original one and
the second one well yeah but the
original was 1974 dude they did a remake
yeah in the 2000s yeah i think we have
that one um which was okay yeah um is
that what he's talking about maybe but i
don't know if they've done another one
since then
now i
i might review
the remake from when was it when did it
come out 2004
i want to say it was 2004. i remember
seeing it back then and i liked it but i
haven't seen it since then so i don't
really know but i might like review at
some point
um
[Music]
we'll see i know they've done like a lot
of other movies since then i've never
seen bonnie and clyde talk about the old
black and white bonnie and clyde or uh
yeah because we didn't i thought we did
that well we did a show about it
okay but we haven't talked about the
movie okay
oh i like the movie
i did as well but i haven't seen it in a
very long time yeah
we might be able to do that put that
down
bonnie o'clock bonnie and clyde movie
and i have to put down like new texas
chainsaw massacre too
bonnie and clyde that was the one with
uh fate denier fade down away
and uh what's his name warren beatty i
think it was yeah it wasn't working
holy [ __ ] how did i pull that out yeah
which those two were did not were they
were not like [ __ ] bonnie god really
in real life yeah but it's the movies
yeah
nobody is like there they were both very
much smaller they were little people
little well
they were cute people they weren't
exactly little people yeah well you know
about they were very i think she was 411
he was like five four
they didn't really weigh anything just
people from another time
poor nutrition yeah back in the old days
yeah
they were cute though
she was really cute she looked like a
little model daniel rowling said the
netflix uh texas chainsaw mascara the
one that just came out okay
i have not seen that
but i will look into it for sure
because
i'm always down for anything that's like
texas chainsaw massacre related
um yeah zach said uh watched it again
recently i forgot how good it was uh
blatantly dude says you can always do a
show on space program deaths both
astronaut and cosmonaut that might be a
good show too because
well what would be interesting along
that line is that there's supposedly a
bunch of cosmonaut deaths that were
hidden
they went all the way back yeah i think
we talked about that one yeah did we
talk about that one that had that that
woman heard the that heard the the radio
signal the girl burning up it's getting
hotter it's getting hotter in here yeah
yeah i don't think it actually happened
but it would be a good it might be a
decent show i don't know
have to see and uh the the russian space
program had a lot of failures that they
hid
so there's probably a lot of [ __ ]
vanished cosmonauts
that we don't talk about yeah they don't
talk about because that would be
admitting failure
camp guy said there's a chainsaw
massacre with matthew mcconaughey very
early in his career yeah that's right um
i think it was called texas chainsaw
massacre what was it called the new
beginning a new beginning something like
that i think it was like um
i saw it a long time ago
and i don't remember that much about it
but
you know i'll revisit it one of these
days we have so many [ __ ] movies we
gotta do yeah
um
it is
9 39.
how long we've been going
three hours and 45 it's time you think
yeah it's time it's almost four hours do
you think it's time yeah it's a long
show
all right
oh he would say yeah texas chainsaw
mascara the next generation that's right
that's what it's called
i saw it one time a long time ago i
don't remember that much about it but
one of these days i'll rewatch it
i kind of feel like was somebody else
famous in that too was renee zellweger
in that or am i thinking of something
else but i remember like renee or uh
matthew mcconaughey being it all right
i'm about you but i'm hungry
well i can't eat i told you
okay
i mean i would like to
there's something low calorie i can make
for you like what uh
we'll see let me guys
i gotta see what i have
okay some kind of little sandwich or
something because i have a bunch of uh
pita bread
that's right you went to the bite you
went to the biker bar yesterday yeah i
have uh a bunch of two back and a bunch
of tuna i can make a little tuna fish
sandwich that doesn't that that's not
much i have a bunch of eggs i can make
an egg sandwich that's that's that's
that's good for you
all right egg sandwich that's gorgeous
eggs and cheese uber or egg sandwich
that matter don't put any cheese on it
okay tell me what you just egg sandwich
i mean just eggs toast i mean salt and
pepper and some kind of flavor okay i do
i mean even it doesn't have to be a
sandwich it could just be like fried
eggs
salt and pepper on it
with toast
yeah okay i can do that just make sure
the
the the uh
yolks are runny so okay so i can dip it
sure and do that that was my favorite
dinner when i was like okay poor yeah
i'll make that for you
uh cam guy said bacon lettuce and
tomatoes in season i had one today yeah
bacon's always in season
all right so we will be back on
what's today friday okay so we'll be
back on sunday talking about whatever
movie we don't know remember you guys
that on the monday matinee show
we're starting to do
a haunting episodes we're going to do
one every week
on monday yeah
so sunday we're going to do a movie and
then monday we're going to do a haunting
episode i don't know which one it's
going to be yet
but
they're fun they are funded yeah come
here come join us live on the haunting
episode yeah i think that'll be fun so
we're going to like start doing that
every monday because that was something
we decided last week
so sunday we we're going to do a movie
but i don't know which one
so you know
it'll be fun anyway
so
thank you for hanging out with us this
friday evening thank you for your super
chats and all of the conversation that
we have this evening yeah and getting
truck with us at the house got drunk
with us at the house yeah and we will
see you guys again on
sunday evening
good night you guys